enough for Girl Scout cookies please be
generous
you got that everybody
all right you ready I am ready you got
the sheets okay
open the hearing on House Bill 548
relative to the definition of compliance
with a legal support order for child
support payments the chair recognizes
the chair of Fish and Game James
Spillane come on up
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee
took me a minute I had to get through
the three and figure out which one was
the one I was bringing up
um because I have three of them here
today but this one
um I'm going to tell the committee that
I would welcome an amendment if they uh
so choose because the first crossout
that's on line five was not something I
did and we don't know how it got there
from OLS unless the department asked for
it so if the department had said they
wanted it they didn't tell me about it
but it was in here and it shouldn't be
that shouldn't be crossed out the only
thing I'm doing here is adding a
definition of what it means to be in
arrears by setting a baseline of 25
dollars and the reason I'm doing this is
because last summer I was denied a
passport from the set the the state the
federal government
um Department of State
my wages are garnished automatically
I'm like how could I possibly be in
arrears
what they do is they take how much would
you pay at the end of the year
total and they divide it up by how many
pay periods you have and that's what
they garnish out of each check and send
along
So currently the the way the law is
written
as soon as Division of Child Support
becomes aware that you're in arrears
they have 30 days to tell the federal
government you're in arrears and you
lose your government services it's not
just passports but lots of other things
I'm sure the chair could Enlighten you
on the different things the federal
government provides that you could lose
and it could be one penny
and for me it was a rounding error
because my pay periods didn't hit at the
exact time that things were due and when
you added them all up by the end of the
year it's totally
equal
but I had to go online with division of
child support make a payment to them in
a in addition to what was normally being
taken out of my check just to make
myself go to exactly zero so I could
then contact again the state department
and tell them would you try processing
my passport again
and now at the end of the year I'm going
to be overpaid and division child
support is going to have to either roll
it over or send me a check back for the
difference because the whole problem
here is the small amount a penny can
kick you into the federal government and
when I talk to this the state department
they said the way the system's set up in
New Hampshire all we get is a red light
or green light a thumbs up a thumbs down
when we ping the system if they're paid
up to date we get a green light or a
thumbs up and if this in a rearage
thumbs down
we can't process it
for for a few pennies rounding I'm sure
this is this happens to other people
um but I wanted to set a Baseline and so
the researchers down at OLS did some
research to find out what is the minimum
amount that somebody might have to pay
for a month and 25 was the smallest
amount that somebody has to pay for
child support so this would mean that uh
that seems to be a good number
that if somebody's in arrears more than
25 now you can notify the federal
government because it's actually a
missed payment or something rather than
just a rounding error
and that's all I have
any questions for Representatives
belaine
I'll be happy during yes representative
Bickford
I'm using 20 thank you Mr chairman thank
you
um using 25 and they said that was the
minimum beat my experience has been it's
usually fifty dollars and did you ever
think of using maybe
um one payment
I did actually say one payment but it
varies so much from Individual to
individual what one payment is that it
would have actually been a higher burden
to the department to try to figure out
what one payment for each person is
rather than have a specific dollar
amount is what I was told I asked all
this with the researcher we went back
and forth a few times because at first I
just said you know it needs to be it
needs to be set up so that it's an
actual missed payment before you
penalize people
and and that this is what they came back
with thank you
representative Raymond
uh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative spleen for coming and for
taking my question
um so I'm still confused about how the
red light green light thing works so if
someone makes a payment for say you make
your your paid by weekday or whatever so
you make your payment this Thursday gets
taken from your check are you now in
arrears until your next pay period so
like how does that this ties in with the
other bill that I had tried to put in
for accrual dates being able to be
chosen
um
whenever they hit their accrual date
with the Department says okay it's due
now
however much they've been sent
counts towards that and if it's off by a
few dollars you're in arrears until the
next
until your the next payment comes from
your company that kicks it now you're
over right and so at various times
throughout the year you're over you're
under you're never dead on that makes
sense and over doesn't harm it over as a
green light but under is not even by a
penny even by a penny
thank you for that I appreciate it
okay thank you for your testimony I will
Trot down to OLS and get an amendment
and the amendment to be doubly sure
simply takes the strikeouts in line five
and six out and keeps the text correct
thank you will do
all right I have one other pink card and
it is Matthew Hayes Bureau of Child
Support Services
foreign
McPherson tie is it clan McPherson looks
familiar
Nautica Mr chairman well sorry I've got
a Nautica all right thank you though
um it was a nice time appreciate that it
is a nice time
so thank you good morning Mr chairman uh
attorney Matthew Hayes from the Bureau
of Child Support Services thank you for
giving us the time to speak about this
bill
um I was
I am here with uh the director of Child
Support who I think you may have met
before at the uh orientation I'll let
you introduce I'll let her introduce
herself real quick
morning Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is Lisa decotowski
with the Bureau of Child Support
Services bureau chief thank you
so we were here to testify on this bill
and provide some information but the the
bulk of my testimony is actually geared
a little bit more towards the portion
that it seems like is not going to be
moving forward I was going to talk most
about why we would like to have the
medical insurance piece that was going
to be repealed left but doesn't sound
like that's going to be an issue so I'll
not talk about that I do have written
testimony prepared as I usually do it
does talk about that I can still give it
to the chair uh to the committee for the
records if they wish
um it sounds like most of the discussion
from the sponsor was about the obligors
A rearage and change or adding a
definition to becoming in compliance to
be if the range is less 25 or less
um
I would say that there will be some
system changes involved with that from a
software standpoint as well as changing
costs associated with changing internal
policies and forms
um
I wasn't going to say that uh
I guess I was curious what the what the
what the reasoning was behind it I I
just learned about it just now so I have
some I'm more prepared I guess to answer
questions about a marriage and
compliance some marriages I'm not sure
if I'm prepared to speak completely to
everything that was just discussed
because like I just said I didn't really
know what the reasoning was prior to
coming here
so I don't know what the committee will
find most helpful
um I guess I'll at least since you want
to add something about the thresholds or
just take questions
oh we could certainly take questions
from the committee I don't think we'll
just take questions okay great any uh
questions representative Craig
so um thank you um
sure thanks Pat and thank you for taking
my question
um sorry it's a Monday Tuesday right uh
anyway I guess I was curious so from
your department do you see I don't hear
that you have any issues with this if we
take that strikeout if that stands is
there any issues from the Department on
something like this
it sounds like the the medical support
piece so the lines five and six are are
not going to be taken out so that's good
uh we want them to stay
um as far as line 15 and adding that
piece
our position would be that would
would like that not to be added uh but I
don't know if I can point to a 4D issue
necessarily with when I say 40 I
apologize I mean a federal a special
provision in the federal government's
cfrs that tell us how to set up our
child support program I don't know I'm
not aware of something like that
specifically being addressed that I can
point to and say that it's going to be
contrary to federal law if you add this
but I can tell you that it will require
us to make changes to our system and
change to our policies and I can at
least say that it could cause some
difficulties with the last payments
so
if for example somebody was owed
a parent was owned not the state but if
a parent was owed
25 dollars
we need to collect that 25 for them
I know it doesn't sound like a lot of
money but it's owed to that parent and
we need in order to complete our
mandate and to close out the case and to
actually completely have all the arrears
paid off we need to make sure we collect
that 25 So in theory I can see it being
complicated uh in terms of not being
able to use our general enforcement
remedies
to collect that last bit of money for
that parent
um
well there's that there's that as well I
can't imagine that's too many cases but
there's that issue okay thank you
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
so in the case of a wage
garnishment and I I just would like to
make a disclosure I am a co-sponsor on
the bill but I do not intend to testify
so but in the case of a wage garnishment
that 25 dollars will be paid with the
next garnishment from the individual's
paycheck so
the system will receive that monies
isn't that correct yeah so there was a
wage garnishment it would be collected I
I think it probably would only come up
if there's a situation where we didn't
have a wage garnishment
somebody was self-employed or we didn't
know where they worked or something like
that but yeah so if there was a wage
garnishment being collected
it would it would be collected
at some point
the compliance piece is only if
somebody's not making payments for a
long period of time
but thank you for the question yes no
thank you
any further questions oh representative
Raymond thank you uh chair so um I feel
like I have to stretch really hard and I
apologize to everyone I just want to be
seen from the corner my question is
pretty much the same as what I had asked
representative Spillane regarding I'm
still unclear as soon as if someone's
wages are being garnished by their
employer one would assume that as long
as they're receiving a paycheck from
their employer and working that they
would never fall into a rear so I I want
to understand how
um
not changing the system could impact
could impact you know something like
this happening again so it makes sense
to me this idea that if you divide up
you know the payments over 52 payments
or you know 26 payments or whatever it
is that you might have the payments be
off by a couple cents each time that
makes sense
um but I guess what I don't understand
is how what other type of solution there
could be to the issue of someone say not
getting a passport or having some other
problem with the federal government
because of a rounding issue that hasn't
really they've not done anything wrong
because we don't we don't want to
penalize parents who are in good faith
cooperating with the system to make sure
that the other parent has what they need
for the children
so how like what are the are there other
options what can we do
um would a different number help I I
guess that's my question
thank you representative Raymond if I
may um I would like to
um clarify
um in the first instance I'd like to
just um make reference to the federal
offset program that you have referenced
as well as
um representative spleen the threshold
for the federal offset program requires
on a rearage balance to accumulate of up
to a hundred and fifty dollars worth of
our marriages due in a public assistance
case so a rarages that would be owed to
the state of New Hampshire in order for
that threshold to be met for an
individual to be submitted to the
federal offset program in a circumstance
where an individual is not receiving
Public Assistance the arrearage balance
would need to accrue up to five hundred
and fifty dollars so there must be that
balance due in arrearages
so payments that had not been made up to
that value before the individual could
be submitted for that particular
enforcement remedy
um certainly in the event that an
individual is paying by an income
assignment
then they would if they've already been
submitted for that previously once you
are submitted you are submitted to the
offset program until you're a rearage
balance is satisfied with a zero balance
at the end of the calendar month so I do
believe that that may have been the
circumstance that the sponsor had been
speaking to previously unfamiliar with
those circumstances this is the first
that our Bureau is hearing of this today
so feel um
unable to best respond to that specific
incidents however in terms of just a
rearages in general the bureau when the
Bureau of Child Support Services
enforcing an order for child support we
look at what is due in the month so if
an individual has a certain monthly
support obligation that is due for the
current month anything that is unpaid
goes into the following month and is
considered arrearages what we would
consider our enforcement activities for
those arrearages would not initiate
until there was a consecutive
non-payment of 60 days so if we hadn't
received any payments on any current or
on any arrearages that were due for
consecutive 60 days than our enforcement
activities would not be an or our
enforcement activities would would be
initiated at that point of non-payment
so in a circumstance where an individual
is paying by an income assignment it may
be a situation where the amount that is
due for the accruals the amount that
child support is to be paid versus the
way that the payments are coming in
there may be some balances due that
carry over but again as long as there's
an income assignment in place we would
not
in take any enforcement activities on
that uh follow-up follow-up thank you
um so in that in that circumstance
um
say for example someone has in a rare
Edge and then they come flush so they've
discovered that they oh and now they
have paid in and they're back to zero
is the threshold another 60 days before
uh another contact with the federal
government for enforcement or is it from
then on if you're even like a cent
behind you're going to be reported the
threshold is always to um the a rearage
balance so that the rearage balance is
set at that 150 dollars and then the 550
whether you're receiving whether it's
arrearages for public assistance versus
non-public Assistance or marriages so
it's um we report that information uh to
the federal offset program at the end of
every calendar month it's built in so
once that reaches zero then that
information gets reported if there are
circumstances where there may be a um
if there are circumstances where there
may be a timing
um challenge there between how our
automated system reports that
information then the bureau is willing
to work with the individual and with the
um the federal offset program to help to
satisfy that uh arrearages that are due
thank you
actually have a quick question is this
something that you could do with your
system on garnish wages knowing that I
mean you must know what week
is going to be ten dollars short or five
dollars short
is that something that you could do in
your system itself
on a week-to-week basis knowing okay
this is five dollars short this week
however next week it's going to be over
at the end of the year they're going to
be even
thank you representative for the
question
um so our income withholding the system
is currently set up if we were able to
identify the frequency of the payments
which I think is very difficult for us
to assess and evaluate if we don't know
if the payments will always be regularly
paid through an income assignment
so each case has to be looked at
individually to be able to make that
assessment and determination
representative DeSimone
thank you Mr chair
um
I'm really stuck on the fact that an
individual
is involved in a wage garnishment
so that individual has zero power as to
how often the payments are made it's
just garnished from his or her wages
yet an individual can be penalized by
the federal government for being behind
for just a few cents is there a way
you're talking about your
quote unquote kind of discussions with
the Federal Branch but if this person is
denied
a passport because of a few cents
isn't it
counterproductive
thank you representative I appreciate
the question
um
the again I um and I was not prepared to
come here today to speak uh fluently in
regards to the federal offset program
and how that particular program works
I'm certainly willing and able to
provide the committee more information
in reference to that certainly if an
individual is
um looking certainly if an individual
had previously been
submitted for the federal offset program
on a rear edge requirement and met that
threshold
to pay the arrears that were due and are
now currently paying uh their current
and ongoing amount by a wage garnishment
the bureau would take those facts and
circumstances into consideration and
look at all of those circumstances again
on a case-by-case basis I believe that
it is difficult for the bureau to
um
State one way or another uh whether or
not it is certainly a hardship as you
had referenced for the obligor the
individual paying again keeping in mind
that our role is to collect and enforce
on current and a rearrages due for the
families that we serve and to assist
with the obligors in engaging and if
there's an income assignment holding in
place we would have to take that into
consideration
um
thank you
any further questions
representative panic
thank you for taking my question
um
how long does it take
from the time you notify the feds
and the FEDS
take off
the no-fly list restriction
so the circle thank you for the question
representative appreciate that
um I would need to clarify the specific
time frame for you and get that
information for you
there is again there are specific
requirements in relation to the federal
offset program and the passport denial
program both are different in how those
are satisfied and the um in the
Transmissions that go between our
department and the Federal Bureau of
fiscal Services is electronic and there
is a um
there can at times be a delay in
processing it's all dependent upon how
the federal bureau receives that I would
need to get that specific time frame for
you though I don't have that available I
have a follow-up question
um so in essence what you're telling me
is if
the person is up to date
the time that it takes
your organization to notify the Federal
the feds
and they were up to date they still can
be penalized and not be able to get a
passport or leave the country is what
you're saying
thank you representative I appreciate
that question also there is a
there is a process in place that allows
us to communicate directly with our
federal passport Partners to inform them
that an individual is in compliance
there's also a telephone number and a
process where the individual who's
responsible to pay the obabor in the
circumstance can also contact
them and we do try to work with our
obligors as quickly as possible to get
them that information when they become
in compliance thank you you're welcome
any further questions CNN thank you oh
those are another one representative
Bickford
thank you Mr chairman
um and thank you
um I've heard a couple of numbers here
150 dollars and uh 550 depending on
whether it's Public Assistance or
otherwise
and so I'm curious if that would be a
better number here and whatever we do
here on this line that we're talking
about is it going to cure the problem
thank you representative
um
I'm not really sure how to answer that
question in terms of what is the best I
I did not have an opportunity to consult
with the sponsor prior to the creation
of this or have any input previously
prior to this so I think that certainly
um you know the bureau would have to
take your question into consideration
and determine what may be a best
solution to this circumstance
um
well what
how much time do you think you need
um I'm
how to thank you I'm not sure how to
answer that in terms of time
um I guess
this depends well what we're not gonna
make a policy
recommendation on this legislation I
guess
our position is can be better to not
have that provision there is when I set
up the outset
um you know if if the committee needs
some additional information on the
federal offset program I certainly do
that and they could take that
consideration when when weighing this
policy decision but I don't know I don't
know if we're able to comment on whether
or not we could change that partial
level
um
well let me clarify if I may I'm I'm
just asking what would fix the problem
not what you want
I think that
was playing with terms of the offset
program is you know those are those are
federal requirements that are placed
upon us that
very much automated process
um and this legislation
generally deals with how New Hampshire
deals with whether in order someone's in
confines or not so we would still have
to report these figures to the federal
government
regardless it will be my understanding
of the offset program so
it is in terms of arrears in general I
know that a lot of questions come up
with the readers
60 days in arrears I mean 60 days
non-payment and I think we talked about
that briefly as well someone could be in
arrears and still be in compliance
I mean someone could get an order
today that's retroactive a couple months
ago and be in arrears
and be in compliance to start making
payments and nothing they've done
nothing wrong
but the figures still need to be
reported to the federal government
and that's the requirement of our
program so I don't know if I I don't
know if we can make a recommendation on
what to do if anything with line 15. uh
one more uh
when we passed and I was here when we
passed wage garnishment
and I I fought it quite a bit because
it's very Draconian and it only takes
certain people
the people from Boston came up because
this committee was not very enthused
about it
and so the folks in Boston came up and
said
you don't pass this you lose 21 million
dollars of your Social Security
um for the money
uh but we found a way to have another
way of doing things which is to have the
accounts that people can in other words
not it's not totally mandatory because
we found a way to do it and that's why
I'm asking you try to find a way
to fix the problem with the fetch
because we got to do something here I
feel
then it may be it may not be quite the
right thing so I'm really it's I'm
asking you again
trying to do something like we did
before
thank you
any further questions
see you none thank you thank you uh the
last card I have is uh Vivian Gerard
thank you chair and members of the
committee
um my name is Vivian Gerard and many of
you have known me as a Silva V Silva
case I've come up here and spoke with
you many times about this very issue
um I I am appalled that child support
can come up here and lie straight to all
of your faces
um child support does not follow the
court orders and in my next testimony I
do have all the backup documentation so
we're talking about uh the wage
assignment yep okay okay now wage
assignments well but the 25 uh dollar uh
total amount of our marriage correct and
if you follow where I'm going you'll see
where I'm going with this so child
support says in 60-day window to pay
partial but what they don't look at is
the people that pay uh that have the
ability to pay and have thousands of
dollars and com in non-compliance the
compliance with legal orders of support
is also what they they say that they
follow and I can certainly show you many
documents here where they've changed the
court orders they've
change the wage assignments they don't
follow
garnishment yes and if you look at yep
and if you look at the wage garnishments
that I have here
I have their audit
I have the previous
um
give me one second
so I have the court orders that say what
the amount should be garnished from the
from the paychecks
when they were supposed to start I even
show the fact that they say that they're
going to take x amount of money out
every single month and that's not what
they're doing they make up their own
rules they say that they're in
compliance with the legal orders of
support based on their their uh bill
here
so they're saying that
they are following court orders ongoing
payments is but are not they're not
being followed based on child support
they do not follow it child support is
not being held accountable for the
following courses we're not seeing where
this ties into the uh so if they're
saying that they're taking out wage
assignments for instance so this person
that was getting garnished uh wasn't
able to get his passport wasn't able to
fly wasn't able no that's what that's
what I'm trying to get to so I have so
in my case there's 46 actually it was 51
000 that were all based on child support
arrears not once was the person losing a
license losing a passport never got any
type of enforcement even though I have a
letter here that says
child support is enforcing so I'd like
to know
you know they are they're up here saying
that this stuff is being followed this
stuff is happening but I can show you
clear
documents right here which you're going
to get in the next package that they are
not following what they're saying that
they're in compliance of doing they're
up here lying to your face saying that
they are in compliance at Fallen orders
okay the chair is going to inter
intercede here and say this testimony I
rule out of order it is not to the point
it may be to another point it is not to
the point of this bill so please take
your seat in the future make sure it is
dead on accurate and brief well if you
look at it it says right there about the
order you may hand out what you wish and
please take your seat
yeah this is uh
this closes the hearing on uh 5 48.
the next hearing is scheduled for 10 10
so we will take a break until then
description
oh
you gotta do it right after here
chairman of Fish and Game representative
James Spillane
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee
um
I brought this bill originally my intent
was to try to uh change things so that
we were not forcing everyone into wage
garnishment automatically I have a good
working relationship with my ex-wife and
was paying her directly while we were
before the final divorce orders came but
when the final orders were
given I was told you can't send her
checks anymore now you must
automatically have the state handle it
and I'm like
why and then that because I wasn't in a
risk and I always thought that
garnishment was something that happened
because you were in arrears or you were
undependable what have you not somebody
who was in good standing and making the
payments all the time
but uh we did the wage garnishment and
it didn't become a problem until uh
my son wanted to go to summer camp and
my ex-wife contacted me said hey can you
pay a little in in advance to make sure
that we can put the deposit down for a
summer camp I said I'd love to but I
talked to
you see what the division of child
support and they said we don't have a
capacity to handle an overpayment
so you can't send us extra to pay to him
up front if if you overpay we're going
to send it back to you we don't know how
to handle an overpayment and if I pay
out of my pocket
there's no record that I made that
payment except for my own check stubs
and then if I it wouldn't be credited
towards my regular child support so I'm
like this is annoying maybe I can fix it
turns out and I I know more about it now
from rep Bickford uh talking about when
you passed the wage garnishment
federal law prohibits us from making it
an option except that an option does
exist
to not wage garnish if both parties
agree to it
that was news to me because in my our in
our divorce process it was we were never
told hey you can avoid wage garnishment
if you both agree to handle it yourself
um if you both sign the thing saying
that you know you want to handle it you
can handle it
and so instead of
making
wage garnishment optional
I was going to do it so you could opt
out of wage garnishment found out that's
not really in compliance with the
federal law i instead changed this bill
to basically be an information one
and it instructs the court that during
the divorce proceedings they shall
notify both parties that they can opt
out of the wage garnishment if both
parties agree
so it informs them of their right to not
have the state get involved if they
don't want the state involved in it
with an exception because I realized
this three exceptions that we need to
keep in mind so I put three exceptions
in here
if either of the parties lives out of
state it won't be an option
that's just a collection issue
if there's a protective order in place
this will not be an option
that's a safety issue
and if there's a history of a rearage
already for child support it will not be
an option
because that's where garnishment becomes
important
so what you see before you now is simply
a bill that says that
the court shall notify every person in
their final divorce decree if there's
chilled child support involved that they
have the right to make an agreement
between themselves both parties to
handle it another way if one of those
three conditions is not applicable
and that the court shall also further
tell them that if they choose that route
they're responsible for keeping records
of their payments and be able to prove
that they made payments on time and all
of that and that's it
I'll take any questions
representative Bickford you bring a
historic knowledge of this subject to us
having served here before
well actually I always want child family
while 10 years ago
that's historical I was there for 12
years that's historic oh okay
um thank you Mr chairman thank you
um
generally we don't write a bill that
says divorce hearing
um it would be for
um any child uh
support issue which would be unmarried
or otherwise married and I can't
remember the language it should be who
is the do you know who the attorney was
that wrote this
I do not remember oh okay I think
there's a number here somewhere that
would identify it there is
um I don't know what they mean though I
but if I continue answering and I thank
you for the question
um I wanted to the reason it said we put
in the divorce hearing was because we
wanted people to know right up front
before they get into the child support
system that they have the option
available to them if they so choose it
it's written into our law but nobody
tells you you have that right
and so all we're trying to say is right
up front let's let them know I certainly
wouldn't object to Any Time a child
support hearing comes up that that is
also notified that they have the right
as part of their child support to make
that choice among themselves as adults
with children that they both co-parent
but that that right exists in our law
I'm not giving them the right they
already have that right yeah I'm just
saying let's make them aware that they
have that right
thank you that's a good idea
representative Nelson
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I um I just have out
of curiosity question for you because my
husband
um paid child support by giving a check
every month directly to his ex and they
then would also you know have these
expenses that would come up camp or you
know half of a co-pay for medical
purposes and then he would just give her
another chest
physically um hand that to her so in in
your example how
um how was that how would that
um
payment for Camp
be provided to your ex
I just gave her check yeah yeah I mean
it was more important for him to go to
Camp than for me to get accredited but I
found out that this was it was just kind
of annoying because she was asking me to
just pay up front a little more extra we
didn't need to have additional child
support to cover this right we always
split those expenses and I was going to
pay for half the camp anyway but she
needed help with her part of the half of
the deposit wanted me to pay early and
it wasn't an option that was available
to me to be credited so just
it went uncredited
I understand thank you
so this has nothing really to do with
deadbeat dads or
um
no Department not doing its job or
anything this is simply communicating
something that we legally may know but
probably wouldn't guess so now we simply
told it exactly this is just letting
um the two
adults
with their co-parented children make a
decision how best to handle the transfer
of payments from one to the other
um and whether it and and the like I
said it's all written in the RSA already
they have the option to both agree to go
outside of that system
um but we're not told that that right
exists did you do any looking around to
see what some other states do because
having lived in several different states
and having numbers of people under my
care
this was how it was done
one of them gave the other one a check
and only if somebody got really bad did
they have to garnish wages and that was
my understanding Mr chairman thank you
for the question uh and why I was
confused that I was being garnished
immediately and it turns out that rep
Bickford could probably tell you more
about this but the feds changed their
regulation
and the state was okay with it because
the state gets money for every case to
handle
so the more that go through the wage
garnishment the more cases they handle
and the more money comes in from the
federal government
you said the state changed its way of
doing it I'm not sure when and that's a
history question what what did they
change did they change that you cannot
agree to do it the way you want to did
that come off the table as as rep
Bickford started to testify the federal
government came in and said you're going
to lose all this Medicaid money if you
don't garnish yeah but that's not saying
you got a garnish that's just saying
we're going to threaten you if you don't
so that was the discussion that happened
here that he talked about you guys
passed a law that said that now we're
going to garnish
but it's still legal in New Hampshire
to do otherwise if both parties agree
and this is just something nobody tells
them that they can agree to do it okay
and you and am I right in saying that
you in anticipating somebody might find
an outlier case where this wouldn't be a
good idea you put in parenth Brackets
four five and six uh to say uh there if
people are in serious arrearage if some
one person's out of state if there's a
protective order so you are answering in
anticipation of those who say there
might be some realistic objections or
correct okay I've hopefully covered
those exceptions where we would really
want to make sure that the state does
handle the payment process I just wanted
to get fixed in my mind what we're
trying to do here
last call any other questions for the
Prime sponsor saying none now you make
thank you
those who are coming up next will
address comments to this specific Bill
to these specific issues or you will be
out of order we will not entertain
stories of what the department did or
didn't do and horror stories and people
you know and you yourself it will be
about this bill or the gavel will fly
again
with that the chair recognizes for three
minutes
Vivian Gerard to speak to this bill
thank you chair and members of the
committee
um as you are all talking about again
the wage Garners garnishments and at the
time of divorce people do get assigned
whether they're have to pay child
support Bureau or if they pay directly
to the payer at the time of my divorce
my ex paid me every single month exactly
what that court order was
as my cases went on and he was ordered
one amount we went to the Supreme Court
it got overruled five times every time
that order changed
the last time that it did it was changed
in 2018
Supreme Court remanded and and made it
payable to the child support Bureau
again and I agree with the previous
statements that every time they get any
type of wage assignments they get credit
for taking in all these arrears and that
was going to be one of my questions is
if if they're constantly showing arrears
on my ex's case why are they not
collecting the exact amount of money
that he should be paying he has plenty
of money to pay the wage assigned amount
does no enforcement happen and they I'm
being told that there's two types of
cases one is a wage garnishment which is
a collection agency only and there's a
title for d
and unless if your title 4D there is no
enforcement on these orders so how are
you objecting to this bill so I feel
that basically on this bill they're
trying to enforce things and and say
that garnishment of wages that become
mandatory and both parties to detail
their preferred form of payment so if we
had a preferred form of payment where I
actually got the check from him then I
wouldn't be dealing with 2018 to 2020
them taking out the wrong amount he
would have been as told to pay the 1666
per the court order and then somebody in
child support put that whole case on
hold it was not their job to put it on
hold their job was to follow the court
order so from 2018 to 2020 and I have
copies of this here but that just showed
that what would you change in the bill I
would change the fact that if two
parties are willing to pay that amount
that in in my case at first it was 1666.
if he paid me the 1666 I would have been
getting that money right along okay
that's the bill that's the law your
objection is somebody didn't follow that
and that is not germane to the bill that
is a complaint you have against somebody
who didn't do their job but what I'm
saying is if if the bill wasn't forced
to pay child support he would have been
paying me directly and he would have
been on time every time
because he had plenty of money to do it
so if you two agreed to that then it
would have happened and that's what this
bill wants but the bill what I'm saying
is somebody in the title 4D through the
state somebody is changing my case okay
that's not the bill that is your case
yeah but the bill shows uh let's see
here
I started on here
so first of all like on part of this it
says that that they shall notify both
parties that hasn't happened okay that's
not the bill the bill says what they
should do if this didn't happen you have
a beef with somebody but it's not here
you're one
non-germaine statement away from ending
your testimony okay well
other whole
problems that you guys are not
anticipating I've been living this for
nine years and I just feel that by you
guys not understanding what is happening
on the real side of life from people
like me and I'm the okay thank you I've
shut your mic off now and I would simply
say that uh
having gotten to know my committee I
think most of us live on the real side
of life
I think most of us have a back story
most of us have some complaints or have
close loved ones who do the chair now
recognizes The Honorable Betty gay
alumna of this committee time to speak
two minutes
by the way Jody if you want to get your
mic close to you we could hardly hear
you last time
no
um I'm just going to comment on a
reference that was made a few minutes
ago about the choice it sounded like it
was the statement was that there's
really no pressure to make people go
through the state when they pay child
support but it's Financial pressure that
exists and in previous bills there's
been an attempt to simplify child
support so that the person who pays the
less unshared support the person who
pays the less is subtracted from the pay
the person who pays the most and you
just have one smaller check being
submitted however in real life
we're always trying to protect our
budgets and whatever dollars we can get
from the federal law are really
attractive so it means we constantly
have this pressure from federal law
to collect and have the money go through
our our child support so that is not
minimal kind of pressure
there's going to be all kind of
encouragement to get people to do that
because our DHHS has to pay the bills so
I just wish that we could change the
federal law so that we don't penalize
our own people making them go through
extra steps
so that's really my my whole comment
that that is a big pressure
so your comment is really to the federal
law but
how about to the bill well the fact is
that the bill is trying to make sure
people know that they have an option not
to go through the state but I think it's
necessary to point it out to people
because the the default is oh you will
pay through the state
excuse me
there is protection for people who are
worried about not being paid to have it
uh to have it on record but as
representative D Simone can tell there's
been real efforts in the past to free
people from this Federal pressure but
money talks and everybody has a budget
will you take questions
sure
does anyone have a question thank you
and welcome back thank you
the chair recognizes
Lisa
I I was saying it so well in my head
decotovski
and I'm going to get this one I know it
Matthew Hayes thank you Mr chairman
thank you Mr chairman
uh thank you Mr chairman members of the
House of Children and Family Law
committee on behalf of the Department of
Health Human Services Bureau of Child
Support Services uh thank you for
letting us speak on HP 618
um I I guess two things I I think on the
outset I didn't there's a number of
changes that are being proposed in this
bill I just kind of want to focus on two
things and I have written testimony I
can submit after
um
and we didn't it wasn't talked about a
whole lot I don't think at the previous
by previous testifiers but uh lines 13
and 14
with respect to changing uh the amount
of a ridge that has to accrue before
a wage assignment that was previously
uh foregone can be initiated again
um I can explain it more in my written
testimony but that would run a file of a
CFR that requires all states to have
that threshold be 30 days and that's why
it's in our statute now written that way
all right before you go on I want to
nail this point down while we're doing
it this is when a ray Rich period
amounting to the support ode for two
months or more has accrued is it the
line item mine are not numbered on my
text oh sorry yes no that's fine um two
months and you say the FED standard is
30 days correct and I had I had the CFR
site in here that uh everyone can look
at later we can fix this so okay we'll
take that problem away and I didn't know
if that was uh that wasn't really
discussed before so I know it sounds
like a lot of the it sounds like the
Spear of the bill is is
getting information to parties about
child support and their options and I
think that we can say that we think
that's a good idea uh I don't think the
bureau has I don't our positions that we
have no issue with people want to agree
to uh have their own direct payment
arrangement created and as we've
mentioned before I think in the past uh
there's many many owners that we never
see
um you know it's only when someone asks
for our services
and when there's State assistance being
provided and then you know we can get
into a whole host of law sets around
that but
um that's generally it I mean if and it
says right on the uniform support order
uh paragraph eight and I can provide a
blank copy of the Uso uh after this via
email
for the committee's reference but it
says on the Uso paragraph eight uh
basically gives the court that space to
make the determinations that by the way
those terminations are also in federal
law uh ways to not have a wage
assignment if that's what the party so
choose
so uh
I don't think there's any issue with
that I think probably the only other
concern that we would have is with
respect to
us developing a form
I don't know if we would be the best
person to do that
um I think that everyone's case is
different every
uh parenting case child support case it
says divorce case in here I think
representative Pickford pointed that out
already though there are other types of
cases that come before the court that
aren't necessarily divorces I don't know
if we would be able to develop a
standard form that would address all
contingencies I think that
the spirit of it is well intentioned and
it makes sense and the more information
people have about
how child support works I think it'll be
advantageous to all parties and
um I just don't know we would be able to
develop a form that would appropriately
address those contingencies I think that
might be best left to uh the court to
explain when the order is issued
um also attorney counsel for the parties
if they have them probably should give
them an idea of how child support Works
um
we're certainly free to be a general
resource if parties wish to reach out to
us I know the court
uh I don't know what the early stages of
the Court's divorce proceedings are but
maybe there's a way to provide them with
our information so we can give them some
ideas about what we offer if people wish
to take advantage of it but unless we
get a specific application from a party
really can't talk to them too much about
their case and we don't provide legal
services so I really can't give them
advice either
but yes
um the more information the better
I think we could agree that the more the
parties know the better that the
proceedings go
so I I don't it would like to add
something uh
Elisa then I'm just happy to take
questions at this point
any questions
representative Bickford
thank you Mr chairman
thank you Mr Hayes
um
on line 15 and 16. it it appears that
that's not I don't see it in the statue
and is that do you see that as an
addition or is that somewhere in the
stature that I'm missing oh I thank you
for the question uh representative
um I agree with you it's not in there
those are those are additions
um I didn't speak about them because I
don't know if there's necessarily
a programmatic issue with with those
um
I don't know if the federal regulations
and our state plan address those
contingencies so I wasn't going to
uh make an issue out of them I would say
that it would I do talk about it in my
written testimony but it would involve
adding procedures and and there must be
a cost associated with adjusting forms
and
our internal policies but I don't know
if there's a programmatic concern with
those two Provisions at least
well I'm thank you Mr chair I'm
concerned with adding more
to that statute without having more
discussion about it I guess
um and
I did see the two months as opposed to
one month here in the statute are these
the only things that are
you know that's actually changing the
law that's going Beyond
notification to the parties
so that's my
concern
um
my preference would be to strike the
additions in the law
I I if I may respond please chairman
um are you referring to I don't have the
current
foreign
statue in front of me but are you
referring to the fact that maybe I'm
because I picked up on this as well that
those two editions sort of change the
notice and the notice requirement that
is found in the uh
opportunity to contest
paragraph I'm looking oh I may um
because it's sort of the way that it's
written does sort of change how
uh the current statute's meant to be
written in terms of notice and
opportunity to be heard
that's what you're referring to I I
agree drafting wise could be problematic
well it's the out-of-state thing and why
that needs to be there
on line 15.
even 16 for that matter I don't see it
goes in the statute or maybe I'm
no it's an addition from the bill excuse
me it is on and the bill does add those
two they're not there before so that
would be a new requirement yes it would
I imagine it would expand wage
garnishments but again I think that our
position is that that would be a policy
decision for this com for the
legislature I think I was going to
comment on those I just want to know if
we saw things the same I I think we do
sir I I agree okay thank you
any further questions
see you then thank you
I would suggest representative Spillane
that you take counsel with Council
um on the way to walking to OLS to
certainly change two months to 30 days
which I don't think we would have any
problem with doing and uh yeah see what
they can what what you want to do
um I missed part of it uh I I do like
the
um three carve outs you made in here I
think that makes the bill good uh better
um than it could have been but um yeah
well if you would not mind walking down
to OLS and and doing an amendment on
that we can have that presented when we
exec the bill
would that bring I bring uh hearing on
House Bill 618 to a close and we have
about a seven minute recess before the
stated time for the next bill and if you
haven't yet bought your Girl Scout
cookies you can do that
thank you
did you sign up for some Girl Scout
cookies
okay
we're going for the state record
chair now opens the hearing on House
Bill 583 an act relative to the
termination of child supports and calls
upon the Bill's Prime sponsor the
chairman of fishing game representative
James Spillane
foreign
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I'm glad you're still
entertaining me here this morning
um
this one is probably going to be the
most controversial of the three that I
presented
um but I hope you'll listen to reason on
it and I'm going to start out by telling
you that my son turns 18 next month
and I encountered this situation again
through personal experience
um
there is a section that's not addressed
by this bill and I'm hoping that
somebody here who hears what the
situation is can come up with an idea
how to fix it because I wasn't by the
deadline of being able to submit bills
to address that portion
but we'll start with that because it's
peripheral to how this bill came about
it gives background and it shows another
issue that does need fixing if somebody
can come up with an amendment they can
put on another bill
knowing that the courts were backed up
following covid my ex-wife and myself
said well you know William's turning 18
in March and he graduates in June
and so we should probably file a joint
motion with the court to change the
child support
um based on him turning 18 and
graduating
and so we did and
it was good that we did
because I found out uh
I had assumed when he turns 18 he would
just fall off and my daughter who's
still on support would get her support
and his would be changed the support
amount would be changed for the fact
that he turned 18 and graduated that is
not the case
if you have more than one child
support continues garnishing your wages
at the same amount once that child turns
18 and graduates and the remaining child
or children continue getting the same
amount of Child Support unless you know
enough to go in and say hey one of them
is
no longer on child support who's 18 now
so we need to change the amount
so in essence what I was paying for two
children would have continued
for one child unless I knew enough to
put the motion in so that's the part
that isn't fixed by this that there is
no automatic way
to change the child support amount when
a child turns 18 and graduates
now the part that is covered by this
is an egregious situation and I have
turned over to the chair
my own uniform support Order final from
the court I have not distributed it to
the committee because it does have
private information in it however he has
the ability to read it and to attest to
what was written in it
the way the law is written it says that
the child must graduate it must turn 18
or graduate whichever happens last
so my child having ADHD and ODD and
we've been battling with multiple IEPs
throughout his schooling and uh urging
him and and helping him get to the point
where he's about to graduate may fall a
few credits short and we're doing
everything we can to make sure he
graduates with his class because he has
told us if he doesn't graduate with his
class he's not going to finish he won't
go back another year and he won't get
his GED he's just going to go into the
trades
and on my uniform support order the
marital master in the court wrote that
because the law says that he must turn
or graduate whichever happens last
that this uniform support order changing
the amount of Child Support is null and
void if he doesn't graduate and that
until he gets his graduation I will
continue paying child support to him
even if he's 24 even if he's 32.
turning 18 does not end the child
support the way it's written now he must
graduate
and it's written right in there
to emphasize the fact that he must
graduate now if this had said whichever
happens first
we wouldn't have this problem because he
turns 18 in March graduates in June he
would be out of the system for turning
18.
but then you might have the situation
where you have a gifted child who
graduates at 16 and then you're
depriving child support for two years
until they turn 18 because
they graduated first so we don't want to
do that
instead my bill here will just strike
the graduation component
if a child decides to quit school on
their own
you shouldn't be or doesn't go back to
finish school you shouldn't be on the
hook while they were a young adult
there's nothing in the law that says
that the child would nothing in that
uniform support order that says after he
turns 18 he even has to still live with
my ex but I still have to send her child
support
so that's the issue we're with now
um this is simply
striking from here
complete his or her high school
education
so that
turning 18 getting married
becoming a member of the armed services
or gets an emancipation through the
court are reasons for termination but
graduation is not
and and that's uh what I hope you will
consider the fact that that uh and if
anybody wants to say this doesn't happen
it's just uh it would never be done that
way I'll now allow the chair to uh
tell you about my court order
having read privately the court order I
will attest that what the representative
says is written in this document
are there any questions for the
representative representative Raymond
um thank you Mr chairman um and thank
you representative Spillane for once
again sharing some of your personal
story with us I appreciate it and I
believe you a hundred percent that
that's what your court order says
because I've seen those court orders
um typically in my experience
those situations
um where it requires graduation are for
our students who have IEPs or some other
type of
um learning disability that requires
them to continue school until they're 21
and I believe we might be considering 22
these days the idea being that these are
not children these are not young adults
who are able to live on their own and
because they don't have the skills to do
so so our education laws consider them
children until they have hit 21 or 22
and thus child support does as well so
my question is
how would this law impact those kids at
18 are those children or I guess young
adults now able to get some other type
of assistance for their living
arrangements thank you for the question
there's another whole section of of
paragraph in here that deals
specifically with children who are
disabled or are pulling Medicaid for
their disability and situations when
it's under a situation I don't have the
law and I'm not really familiar with it
but it comes under a heading of
situations when child support may be
extended beyond the normal
time of turning 18. this paragraph was
only dealing with the standard automatic
termination of Child Support which as I
mentioned
Isn't So automatic if you have more than
one child you have to actually go back
and ask them to change the amount
because otherwise it just keeps going if
I had five kids and I was paying two two
to four thousand dollars a month and all
of them turned 18 but one I'd be paying
four thousand dollars five thousand
dollars a month for one child
um unless I knew enough to go back to
the court and ask them to change it but
that's not part of this bill so I won't
digress too much before the chairman
gavels me out on that one
um so if I were to I'll pull it up if I
pull up 461
a it'll be under there there should be a
section that talks about uh reasons why
child support may be extended beyond the
normal period and it's some of the
reasons we're disabled children those
who are pulling Social Security benefits
um
um because of a disability Etc and I
believe it does mention 2122 or
something in there thank you for putting
me in the right direction yep
representative Grossman
chair thank you representative for
coming before us
um so
I have a situation I have an 18 year old
son who has an IEP who's a senior at
Exeter High School I'm currently not
involved in divorce proceedings but
his birthday was February 2nd so under
this
Port would end for him
I didn't know how else to deal with this
because we do have a situation where
um I mean I I toyed with ideas of saying
um the June of the graduating of the
June of the year that he turns 18 uh you
know but you're always going to have
somebody that's on an outlying situation
um and like I said my my son turns 18 in
March graduates in June if this was the
law at the time right now yes the child
support would technically end in March
but I have an understanding with my ex
that I'm continuing to June anyway when
he graduates so it wouldn't have
affected us with our own situation
because that's our own personal
agreement but
follow-up it could affect others um
there will always be someone on the
outliers yes and then I guess I would
need some clarification in terms of
I've had families come to me that have
children with disabilities
and their child support ends at 18 very
specifically that there is no longer
support after that 18 so I'm curious
about the law and how it handles
children with disabilities in so in my
case my son will be part of extra School
District until he's 22. that's the new
law change
um but if we were in divorce
I'm confused the section about when it
can extend that the other representative
was asking me about would cover that
situation and that's an agreement
between the two people there's actually
a section of law that says reasons why
there may be a determination by the
court to continue child support Beyond
18. and under there are many reasons or
things listed that could be a reason why
the court could decide that you are
still obligated to continue your child
support beyond the time of 18. and
that's actually written in there in a
section of when can the court consider
going longer
representative Nelson I think you may
have some language that helps here
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um I do and I am open to other people
suggesting maybe better a wording
um I completely get where you're coming
from representative
um I do have
um
thumb pause about turning the age of 18
period because there are a lot of kids
who are born in January February March
April May and from experience in my own
family there's a child who just turned
18 in January and will be graduating in
June and that support order is keeping
him in his home you know where the money
is very tight so I was thinking that
might be the case with other people I
don't necessarily think it's maybe an
outlier situation so would you be
amenable to something like saying and
provided they are attending High School
I I looked at a lot of different options
and I'm certainly the whole reason it's
in front of the committee is so the
committee can discuss where there may be
some shortcomings and what we can do to
go around those but still solve the
problem uh of a perfectly uh able-bodied
child who decides to quit school at 17
turning 18 and still collecting child
support because they don't want to
graduate so I'm open to all of the ideas
that come before the committee I feel
like it's a situation that you know
needs to be fixed
certainly to see it written in a court
order against myself to say wait wait a
minute you know and neither one of us
could believe that that they were saying
this and we came to our own agreement
that if I have to keep paying it they'll
just pay it back to me but that's just
kind of annoying
um and
um and for how long because there's
nothing in there that ever says it has
to cut off for him the way that it's
written
thank you appreciate it
chair recognizes representative ball for
a question
thank you for recognizing me chairman
um so if it um
were to say something like
July 1st of the child's 18th birthday
the year of the year of the 18th
birthday if attending high school or if
attending an approved school like a high
school or a trade school or something
that they would at least finish out that
year keep in mind we have a lot of
homeschooled kids too at this point I
would be wary of any language that says
they must be attending a school uh they
could be doing the senior year of their
homeschooling and then continuing their
education yeah something like that but
somehow end it so that at least they get
through that year of their 18th year to
the end sure as long as it's clear
enough to not also bring in trade
schools that they want to go to next or
um you know because we're not trying to
force parents that's part of the other
agreement that they make am I going to
cover College am I going to cover these
things and that's agreements that are
made in the final divorce decree and we
don't want to put something in place
that makes it untenable for them to come
to an agreement by forcing a situation
where now somebody's being forced to pay
for the schooling going beyond what was
agreed to already so
um
obviously this is dealing we're trying
to constrain this to the high school
period right that's what I was trying to
say within that 18th at least within the
18th year and the acquisition of a GED
you know would terminate that too I
think but the way it's written it says
he it doesn't say that it just says uh
that if he doesn't get enough credits to
graduate
I continue
until he does now doesn't say until he
takes his GED says he till he gets the
credits
if he quit school he just he's never
going to get those credits so there's a
problem there and it's it's basically
comes down to the way this is written to
say whichever is later
you know and that whichever is later
puts you in this bind of it may never
come
later may never come so we need to have
a later
that is that is a thing that's going to
happen at some point so that there it
will always be an end to it
thank you
representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
and testifying
um you know so there's something my kids
get Social Security because their um
their father died so there's something
they have some wording and I can't I
can't find it right now but I'd be
willing to talk to you and look at that
because they have some kind of wording
where
um it doesn't continue on forever it
happens either when they turn 18 or my
daughter was 18 in November hers goes if
when she turns 18 she's only 16. but
um then it doesn't end until she
graduates so she gets to graduate but
they have they have a pretty tight
provision
so I'd be willing to look at my
paperwork at home and then talk to you
about that if this model language
somewhere that's being used by the
Social Security Department already to
make sure that they end their benefits
at a certain time it's worth looking
into yeah so if you would be willing I'd
love to talk to you about that
any other questions for the
representative seeing none thank you so
much thank you and
the chair recognizes Keith kernig from
waypoints who says he will be speaking
against the bill
for three minutes
um Mr chairman of members of the
committee for the record my name is
Keith kenning I'm the average advocacy
director at Waypoint we sit in
opposition to this bill
um after listening to the sponsor
um there's sounds that like there are a
lot of problems that need to be solved
but I don't think this bill answers
those
um and taking out the language of or put
taking out the language and only leaving
when the person turns 18. just seems to
me that
it's a one-size-fits all to try to make
kids and kids are not that way let me
give you some what ifs what ifs and I
can share something personal what if you
have a younger brother who's only
four years younger than you but the
parents have decided that they need to
hold him back here because they think it
would do him better to go in a year
later so he graduates five years behind
me and then what if your parents as mine
did got divorced and so they've made a
decision about their child and my
brother entered high school he entered
his senior year as an 18 year old he
graduated he holds down a job he did
everything he's supposed to do but
imagine if that
support had been cut off as he was going
into his senior year
what about my son
between his junior he was one semester
away from graduating from college he got
a severe concussion
what if that had happened during his
junior year or his his first semester in
high school do we cut off child support
at that point
children we all want to believe that we
have expectations with our children and
if anybody has a child that just doesn't
hold true you have to adapt to what your
child needs and so I'm thinking about 50
other things we could talk about
depression I think they say now a third
of young teenage girls are severely
depressed what if someone has to drop
out for a semester because they can't
hold it together but they want to go
back and get their degree or what about
substance abuse or what about just the
medical injury so I I hear the sponsor I
think he's trying to solve a problem but
the the way this bill is written this
one-size-fits all is not the answer and
it's going to leave a lot of kids out
there having to choose between getting
their education which I think we all
want don't we don't we want them in this
high-tech world to get their education
or they're going to have to be forced
they may not be able to continue their
education and go to school so
I would ask the committee if you're
going to do something like this I think
we need to figure out you know 22 and
the right language
um but not just eliminate this because
it just seems to me it's going to put a
lot of kids in a really bad situation so
thank you for your time and happy to
answer any questions any questions
representative Raymond
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
so much for being here on behalf of
Waypoint
um I just Waypoint still run foster
homes
we do we and and so my question then is
what what effect would you see this
having on kids in foster care because I
know we have like a thousand kids in
foster care right now so thank you for
your question we run something called an
ISO program it's the Intensive service
option and I will not share with you
some of the horrible things these
children have been through at the hands
of their parents
it is beyond belief but a lot of those
kids literally need a team of people
six to ten people working with them
through a weekly basis to stabilize them
and move them forward
if if you had child support in this
situation there are a lot of those kids
that don't make it through high school
by the time they're 18. you know I I in
the perfect world every child fits every
perfect timing of the school and
everything that goes forward I have not
found that perfect world and and and it
just seems to me this bill is a like I
said a one-size-fits all trying to solve
a problem that we need there needs to be
more thought with this and it's much
more of an intricate situation that I
think the bill represents right now I
hope that answered your question
any further questions
thank you so much thank you chair
recognizes representative Deborah D
Simone
thank you Mr chairman and thank you to
the committee I'm Deborah D Simone I
represent Rockingham 14
Atkinson
um I just wanted to say a few things uh
concerning this bill
I am in support of the bill
and with all due respect to uh Waypoint
in all the amazing work that they do for
the children of our state
I think that we need to take into
consideration the fact that
they are correct uh when a child
suffers
from the issue of divorce
sometimes those children ages 16 and 17
just don't want anything more to do with
their families so they apply for and in
some cases are granted emancipation
now if this child is granted in
emancipation
at that point there are a multitude of
ways that they can support themselves
and if that's their choice and they do a
good job of it and most of them do the
law specifically States at 18 years old
that comes to an end
so if emancipation can come to an end at
18.
when they become a legal adult
why would a parent
have to pay child support if
according to statistical information a
child decides to drop out of school now
I don't Advocate that I think that
that's probably one area where I would
use the S word
meaning stupid
um and and I mean no disrespect but I
think that every child should finish
school it
it just is however according to
statistics in New Hampshire
2.7 percent of the kids in New Hampshire
didn't even finish the ninth grade
isn't that sad
um
6.2 percent will not graduate high
school
so if you're a an 18 year old
and you choose not to finish high school
it's a very poor choice
however
doesn't it
make it easier for that child to do that
while
that child is still being supported by
the parents
instead of
pointing that child in the direction of
becoming more responsible
and if they choose to make the bad
choice of quitting school
um get a job
and maybe that will force them to go
back to school and get their diploma
or their GED
I don't think that parents need to be on
the hook to support their children who
are not going to make good choices once
they turn 18.
thank you
any questions for the representative
seeing none thank you the chair
recognizes
they said
dekatowski and Matthew Hayes from the
Bureau of Child Support Services
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
House children family law committee on
behalf of the State of New Hampshire
Department of Health and Human Services
and Bureau of Child Support Services I
thank you for giving us the opportunity
to briefly speak on HB 83 583
um I just want to say at the outset that
obviously uh the bureau's position is
that child support is a vital resource
for New Hampshire families
and uh I can say that in many cases that
we've seen dependents generally a lot of
dependents do turn 18 prior to
graduating high school and that as such
this bill could result in less child
support being collected for those
families and that would result in in
some hardships for families and it would
couldn't result and the increased need
to turn to public assistance to help
those families through those last for
that last time period
um
in addition you know this bill would
have some impacts on our program however
I think it's
up to this up to this Committee in the
legislature to make a policy decision on
how they invest
um see fit to draft it and it's our hope
that if there's changes they can make
changes that are
advantageous to families in the state
state New Hampshire I'm happy to take
some questions as well unless a director
has any input
seeing none thank you so much thank you
chair recognizes Attorney Richard head
from the judicial branch
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Richard head I'm
the government Affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch
um I have a very uh small technical
request in terms of of this bill which
is a change to the effective date from
60 days to January 1. the reason for
that is RSA 14 colon 9 talks about when
effective dates should be set and it
says each law affecting judicial
practice and procedure shall take effect
January 1 following passage because we
have standing orders and forms that
incorporate the current language of this
bill and we get a number of form changes
and various document changes that we
have to do in the course of following a
legislative session
the the law provides for a January 1
effective date we do not have a position
on the policy of the bill only a
technical request I've spoken to
representative Spillane he actually
brought it up to my attention before the
hearing
and asked me about that so I appreciate
his pointing that out
any questions
saying none thank you and with this I
close the hearing on House Bill 583
representative Spillane looks like you
got some people who want to
tweak and work and fix and I would check
please line 10 I wonder if the age is
now 22 from the work I do with the DD
Community I wonder if 22 is the correct
age so while you're tweaking and working
and so on have some fun you got a lot of
people here who want to help you
I've given the committee's school
vacation week off so they'll be around
with this I opened the hearing on the
house resolution HR 15.
14. okay we will make that change to the
pink card
say again
not my problem have fun find out
14 yes indeed a resolution to urge the
investigation of due process and family
court cases the chair recognizes the
prime sponsor The Honorable J.D Bernardi
thank you chairman Pearson and the child
family law committee my name is JD
Bernardi I represent Rockingham 36 which
is Hampton Falls
Kensington Southampton Newton and
Plaistow
I rise today to introduce and support
H.R 14. now passage of this resolution
would establish a committee of either
the members of this committee or a
select committee to be appointed by the
speaker
and its purpose is to investigate the
allegations of denial of due process of
participants in the current Court Family
Division
note
this is a house resolution for a purpose
because the other body I.E what we call
the Senate uh despite numerous bills
that have been passed by the house
attempting to address various due
process issues has repeatedly failed to
move them forward
further this resolution does not require
gubernatorial approval
the authorized committee would have the
power to subpoena and compel attendance
of state officers including Juris and
dcyf employees
one may also consider including the
ability to issue a transport order to
get those in jail to testify
the kinds of due process violations that
could be investigated and you have heard
about already in in earlier in earlier
bills is the waiver and suspension of
court rules rule 1.2 permits the court
to waive any rule in the Family Court
that's not prohibited by a law rule 2.2
permits the court to waive Rules of
Evidence because they are not deemed to
apply you'll hear again legitimate
testimony where the existence or falsity
of abusive relationships was denied when
that testimony could have been
determinative of a fair and just order
at a minimum
all these all waivers should be
explained for the Appellate record
the investigation
could also assess the issue of Court
recordings which are inaccurate because
they have been electronically stopped in
order to exclude offensive or
inappropriate judicial comments
and hence the recordings result in
inaccurate or incomplete Court
transcripts that are the basis of of
legal appeal
the commission can investigate the
repeated failure of the court to follow
statutory timelines which adversely
impacts children and parents
there appearance from testimony offered
a financial benefit to the court from
protracted cases with endless streams of
hearings without final resolution
it should be noted that although the
district and probate courts have limits
on the income of Judges the Family
Division has no similar limit I refer
you to RSA 491 a
the complex and protracted cases also
appear to be re be a repeated
combination of the same judge or Master
Guardian metal item and therapist
a legitimate question is are there
Financial ties to contractors and
Associates that are influencing
decisions
numerous problems have been reported
with the Bureau of Child Support
Services in the proper and uniform
accounting of child support payments
male Administration here could be
devastating to parents relying on proper
management of court-ordered payments
this is also an area for legitimate
investigation
finally you've heard of too many cases
where it appears the reunification
standard has been inappropriately
applied
the denial of the existence of abusive
relationships as a rationale for not
reconciling has not been appropriately
considered
too often a parent feels that the loss
of their child may be the consequence of
non-compliance with the court
the family court has unlimited Equity
jurisdiction
without the same kind of constraints and
regulations and laws that govern the
district court and the Probate Court
essentially the testimony that you're
going to hear
following me concerns a myriad of due
process failures
and
have I and and because of arbitrary
judicial discretion that is often
unsubstantiated and without
justification the record does not
justify the the decisions made
they cry out for an investigation to
determine their veracity and the
definition of a plan to remediate any
truths revealed
I've distributed and I think it's going
around there's there's four testimonies
of individuals who who cannot be here
who have submitted them through the
portal for your review and knowing the
volume of these things that you that
you're getting I just wanted to
highlight uh these four
from The Honorable Dan Itza who served
on this committee for 16 years and in
his last term the 17 through 18 was its
Vice chair
he makes the point that the laws
ultimately should not be causing abuse
to our children it is it it must permit
responsible parent or parents to provide
for their care and protection he
supports the resolution
Paula Verma
a retired New Hampshire attorney and I
hope I didn't mess up her name too badly
who has focused on child and family law
issues
conducted an audit of abuses in the
Rockingham County uh system in 2012. she
supports the resolution and strongly
recommends that the judicial guide to
child safety and custody cases by the
National Council of juvenile and family
court judges be a starting point
Shauna Brown another retired New
Hampshire tournament makes the case that
perjury is a major problem in family
court cases and finally Alice Giordano a
veteran journalist with the Boston Globe
the AP the New York Times and now The
Epic Times
she has personal involvement in the
system herself
I want to read one quote in my 30 years
as an investigative journalist I've
never come across government corruption
so egregious as the corruption in the
family court system with New Hampshire
leading the pack
I strongly commend you to read your
entire testimony
and I also received the testimony of
a young person who was impacted by the
court system and I only have one copy so
I'm going to read this a portion of this
for you and then hand it to you
I cannot be here today because of the
trauma I suffered as a result of written
orders that were full of unsubstantiated
imperative disdain for my mother orders
that ultimately would lead to a new
series of trauma and harm
you see I've done I was diagnosed with
severe complex PTSD at 18 after
returning from being kidnapped the
diagnosis as a result of years of
emotional abuse gaslighting medical
neglect and more and more at the hands
of my father at 25 I continue to place
my mental health as a priority and I'm
in productive form of therapy
it was decided that testifying and
hearing other similar stories could
cause me severe setbacks this abuse was
preventable had the court accepted my
parents final divorce divorce decree and
family history evidence upon entering
the family court system
my experience is only one of thousands
of children's being put through the harm
and significant trauma at the time at a
time in their lives when they should be
flourishing learning and feeling safe
as a child I had a caring parent who
protected us from abuse and harm our
respect this rooted in how our mother
gave great love and respect to us always
showing us the world and encouraging our
growth we kids had safe and were safe
and secure with her and with one another
the court stripped that right from us
the safety from us and by doing I
believe perpetuated future harm that we
are all going to suffer
orders rooted in New Hampshire rule 2.2
this is the evidence rules do not apply
I ask your consideration through this
process and any process you're after to
bring your thoughts back to these
questions does HR 15 follow a just and
unbiased path that could result in
healthy outcomes for all
children included does this resolution
contribute to healthy public policy
preventing
decision-making authorities from
benefiting from extended suffering of
others
if the answer to these questions is yes
then it is my from my experience in
moral opinion H.R 14 could be the
beginning to rebuild justice for all
please take my story and apply to all
the thousands of voiceless children
that have been abused and put in danger
because of failures and due process and
Rules of Evidence think about New
Hampshire's children that you will not
hear today with stories like mine
prevention over everything else
so the bottom line is
this resolution offers you an
opportunity to investigate the truth of
these kinds of circumstances are they
really happening or are they not
it's it's a simple question and and the
committee upon investigation can make
that decision and if they find there are
abuses there are problems can propose
legitimate fixes if they find there
aren't any then there's nothing more to
do
willing to answer any questions any
questions for the representative
seeing none thank you so much
in cases like this where the person
presenting the bill makes a very
thorough presentation the chair chooses
to take one person in effect to be the
chief rebuttal
after that
we will go into the three-minute rule
and your testimonies will be limited
accordingly it would not be fair in my
opinion to go to that three-minute rule
right now so the chair would ask the
honorable Bob Lynn
you have as much time sir as you need
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee I I signed the card saying I
oppose this bill and
and I get I guess what I would really
say that I don't
far be it for me
to say that the legislature you know
doesn't have it doesn't have the
authority or that it that it wouldn't be
appropriate in some circumstances to
investigate another branch of government
I don't say that at all
um
but I am really concerned and I guess
what I'd like to do is just raise it
raise several of the things that concern
me about this resolution to hope that
you'll think about it and then come to
you know what you think is an
appropriate determination on this bill
the first thing I'm concerned about is I
can't help thinking that
um this is deja vu all over again so to
speak because if I recall wasn't there a
Sim weren't there similar allegations
made back around in the
2010-2012 time period where there was a
committee for redress of grievances
formed and one of the or number of the
allegations were that
um you know the judicial branch Family
Division had been the judges were
corrupt and biased and they made
decisions without uh uh without uh
proper a proper basis and as I
understand it
when the when the when all was said and
done and people actually for example
looked at the transcript or the tape of
something where somebody said oh the
judge just made this decision there was
absolutely no reason for it well when
you go and look at the tape of what
happened it turns out there actually was
a reason for what the judge did
um and so I'm I'm
I guess what I'm saying is I'm really
skeptical
about
what you're likely to find now that
doesn't mean that you know can I say
absolutely that there's no no basis for
any of this stuff no I can't say that
but I can say that I'm skeptical
and what I can the other thing that I
can say is I think it's really important
that you understand that you
that what you the the the information
that is often being provided to you in
fact I think probably exclusively in
these allegations is you're hearing
complaints that either directly or
indirectly because somebody has
complained to their legislator
of people who are litigants and are one
side of the story and most of the time
they are people who have lost in the
litigation
so they've come and told their lit told
their legislator this this terrible
thing happened to me the judge was
biased he didn't he he or she waived the
rules when they shouldn't have and all
this
you've never heard from the other side
of the story you've never heard the
litigants on the other side what they
have to say and of course they're not
going to come in they've they've
prevailed in that litigation they have
no reason to come in and and talk to you
and so I guess what I'm saying is
it's it's really important it seems to
me that if for example you decide that
you want to the or the house decides
that it wants to conduct some kind of an
investigation I would think that the
first thing that you that that committee
should do would be to go read the tapes
and listen listen to the tapes or even
order the transcript of the particular
cases where somebody is complaining and
and see
both sides of the story what each
litigant presented to the court what the
judge said as to what he or she uh was
the basis for their ruling and I suspect
um that you're going to find a you know
a completely different story and I'll
just you know I'll just give you a
couple of examples I've heard
um not not from the representative who
testified before me but but I've heard
in the past from Representatives
tell me stories of things that judges
did
that
you know I I spent 26 years in the court
system I think I have a pretty good idea
of sort of how things operate and the
when I would hear that story I would say
to the person well did you you know did
you talk to the person on the other side
no did you look at the at the tape of
the thing no and it in many of those
circumstances it was really clear to me
that
you know if I imagine the worst judge I
could possibly think of in New Hampshire
and I assumed that that judge had spent
the night before drinking and was
intoxicated he or she would never have
done what was alleged if that if the
story was only what the what the
representative had been told had been
told which led me to believe there is
another side of the story that we that
you know the the complainant didn't
bother to tell the uh the representative
who brought that forward
so
these are some of the concerns I had let
me give you another a another example of
something I think is really important
if you look at the the record of the
judicial conduct committee that's the
committee that that investigates judges
for misconduct
you will find that the overwhelming
majority
of the complaints filed against judges
are in family court cases because those
are the ones that generate the most
emotion and hard feelings and you know
angst among the litigants that's the
overwhelming majority of them and if you
also if if we're to look at that you'd
find that the overwhelming majority of
those cases are dismissed finding no
judicial misconduct because what the
complaint is about is a litigant who
lost has made a complaint that the judge
was biased or the judge you know didn't
uh didn't see things the way that the
litigant does and in fact that's not you
know that's not misconduct I mean I you
know the the thing that I think some
people unfortunately have a real
difficult time accepting and I do I use
just the you know the the very basic
example
if I'm the judge and the question is did
one of you drive through a red light or
not and you say the light was green when
I drove through it and another witness
says the light was red when you drove
through it
the judge has got to decide that he's
got he or she has got to decide what is
the truth and if the judge decides that
I'm contrary to what you said the light
was red
you may not be very happy about that at
all but if you go to your legislator and
say you're the only you know the light
was clearly green but the judge the the
judge found it was red and there was no
evidence of that
well you know that conveniently left out
of that scenario is the fact that
they're another witness testified that
the light was red
that unfortunately as I I think is what
is what is likely Happening Here
the last point I would make I think this
is particularly important is to the
extent that this that this um
resolution purports to request to
suggest that this committee would have
subpoena power and that would it would
subpoena judges
I think you're going to run into a real
problem there because
judges cannot if you're talking about
any case that's still pending and some
of these cases go on for years and years
and years the judge cannot will not be
able to respond to inquiries the judge
cannot answer your questions it would be
a violation of the code of judicial
conduct for here for him or her to do so
the rule even with cases that have been
you know that are sort of over I mean in
family law cases K even when a case has
been gone to the Supreme Court and has
been you know reviewed by the Supreme
Court that often is not the end of the
matter there may be further proceedings
and so the case may not even though it
may look like it's over it may not be
over
and so again that would present a real
problem with judges being able to
testify in those cases I think frankly
they would say that they could not I
mean if I were a judge in that position
that's what I would say and I think you
don't want to end up in a situation of
you know of some some kind of separation
of powers constitutional issue there's
just no reason no reason to do that
so I guess what I want to sort of
Express generally about this is
I'm very skeptical that there's really a
basis for an investigation and the ideas
of you know the idea that judges are
corrupt and that they have been uh you
know that they're somehow uh on the I
guess on the take to to make to prolong
cases so that they can somehow get money
out of it
um
really really skeptical about that but I
hate you know I don't want to be the one
to say oh no it couldn't possibly happen
could it possibly happen I suppose
what I would suggest though is before
the legislature spent there's a lot of
money
on this if you're going to do anything I
would suggest at the at as a first step
to say look all right let's take let's
let's find a few of the cases that we
think raised the most concern for you
and have somebody go read the transcript
of those cases order the transcript read
the transcript or listen to the tape and
then make an initial assessment okay
we've now we've now heard word for word
what happened in those proceedings
um what do we think do we think there's
a basis to take some further some
further step I suspect you're going to
find in in virtually all of the cases
that there isn't any reason to do that
um but you know but if you but if it
turns out that there is then by all
means you should go further
uh with that Mr I'm happy to take any
questions and I thank you for giving me
your time
representative McMahon
thank you Mr chairman
uh representative Lynn uh specific to
your last comment you made does line
five and six speak directly five six and
seven of the bills speak directly to
that recommendation
yeah well I I mean it it worded pretty
broadly but um the
so I I don't know that it's sort of
specifically says that we that um
you know that you should do it in the
following manner by sort of looking at
the transcript first but I think that
would probably
um you know that would to me that would
be the way that would make the most
sense and be sort of the most economic
the most productive of your
you know finding out if there's a basis
to look at to to see if there's some if
they're If there really is a basis to go
further that's what I would say
um follow-up
to stipulate to what you just stated
then should there be further detail in
the narrative
in certain terms of The Narrative of the
resolution yeah you know what is that
that's not that's really a very good
idea you might want to say for example
you might want to say that we will
um the legislature will
um you know select uh from some cases
where from those cases where it appears
that they're you know that that um the
allegations are
um are particularly specific of
something of something in particular
being wrong and we will assign uh people
to go and read the transcript of those
cases and see what you know if in fact
from doing that you you have a basic you
you come away saying well you know we've
looked at the transcript now we've sort
of seen everything that appeared to
happen before the judge and we still
have a question and if you do then by
all means that I'm not suggesting you
know I I as I said at the very beginning
the last thing I want to say is that the
judicial branch is like absolutely
Beyond touch it shouldn't it shouldn't
be Untouchable you should have the right
to look at it I'm just sort of saying I
I'm skeptical
um about the allegations and
um you should I guess approach it in a
sober manner is what the way I put it
thank you representative D Simone
thank you Mr
to the representative uh for taking my
question
do you offhand have any idea how many
justices have been removed from the
bench in the last
five years the last five years well I
believe that there's probably there's
two that I know of
um and
one I one resigned I won a marital
master I think resigned under uh you
know under circumstances that released
raised a question yes
follow up thank you Mr chair
[Music]
s
um the judicial conduct committee is
working their best to do their job I
think I think they are I think they do a
very good job you know sometimes you if
does that mean that they you know that
they have sort of advanced knowledge
that somebody has has done something
wrong no they typically don't but I
think when they you know when they get
information that suggests that there's a
problem with a judge
they take action that's been my
experience
representative Bickford thank you Mr
chairman
thank you Judge Lynn
to the power of two subpoena is that a
problem here or not
well I think in in terms The subpoena
itself probably not I think you know if
you're the
the the problem would be if you're if
you if somebody says to a judge I want
you to tell me why you did what you did
that would be the problem because the
judge the judge is not allowed to do
that all right follow up
follow up
thank you Mr chair
um
I certainly would welcome your input for
an amendment for something like this
um because I think it goes beyond the
redress issue that was going on before
uh my
uh since I've been back
I've noticed a disconnect with the
courts and understanding of what they do
if
I can speak for myself this there's
something coming up
and we've been told not to do it a paid
person from the courts has told us don't
do it then we've had other people say
come in and do it but I go like I know
something I think I need more
information I would like I would really
welcome having some kind of a study to
do I was creatively of the family law
task force I don't know if you recall
that or not and we came up with an
incredible uh things because of the
information we shared amongst the
judicial members
in child support and other people the
same thing with um with child support I
was on two of those representative to
the point and then stopped please we
went around well I'm what I'm doing is
I'm saying I would welcome some positive
input because I think we need that kind
of I think we need something to study to
look at and understand the system
okay well sure no I mean I would be
happy to work with the with with the
committee or or any you know or you or
any members of the committee to to try
to you know draft some language that
um
along the lines of what I said if that
if that makes sense
yes I
good thank you uh chief justice thank
you for coming up and testifying today
appreciate that thank you very much
thank you
now we go into the three-minute rule and
three minutes means 180 seconds and I
can shut your mic off and the reason for
that is there's a lot of cards here
and I will say it is three minutes be
careful about always be careful about
slander and libel
um
and make your point and make your point
to this resolution give us a reason why
you think this resolution is good or
this resolution is not and again three
minutes the chair recognizes uh Rochelle
pujay
did I have that right
turn your microphone on please
there you go now the clock starts okay
my name is Rochelle puje and I support
the HR 14. I would like you to know that
my case has been going on for 10 years
and it is a case that involves extensive
amount of abuse Financial abuse
emotional abuse physical abuse and the
cover-up of those abuses by the New
Boston Police Department a guardian ad
litem
and multiple judges in the family court
system
to begin with I'd like to tell you who
some of the judges were in my case and
the only reason I'm here and able to
speak to you today is because my
ex-husband is now deceased and I've had
my daughter back since she was 11
full-time
I'm also a teacher who had to go out on
medical disability
for a permanent permanent medical
disability for PTSD anxiety depression
and other health related issues because
of this
my first judge was Paul Moore he has
been disbarred my second judge was
Philip cross he's been impeached but
allowed to return as a marital master
and a referee or a referee my third
judge was Julie intercasso who had to
resign after whiteout felonies my fourth
judge was Bruce delpra who also resigned
after all of his court cases were taken
away by the Supreme Court
the cover-up of police abuse Guardian El
item abuse attorney abuse medical
neglect child molestation which my
daughter was molested
and just judicial abuse has gone on for
too long the JC
the John Coughlin County attorney won't
investigate real estate fraud that could
possibly involve his wife and now our
home has been taken away from us due to
this fraud
there have been tampering with Lobby
videos that the Department of Justice
refuses to have forensically examined
even though I've had them forensically
examined and paid three thousand dollars
and they have been tampered with they
have been edited and muted while the
video is still running to obstruct
Justice the guardian ad litem in my case
routinely
does not investigate cases blocks you
from getting a copy of her gal file
during investigations
extends gal fees ex needlessly extends
those fees and needlessly extends gal
cases so that she can profit from this
she removes parental rights like she did
with mine to avoid having hearings about
the termination of the Guardian Ad Litem
which was coming up in my case I had a
four-day hearing coming up but they went
in and took my parental rights after I
reported an accurate second dcyf mole
station or molestation incident
involving my daughter that was verified
after my parental rights were taken away
after I was forced into mediation under
extreme duress you have 15 seconds and
after
um I'm sorry sorry I don't mean to
cuss
um
sorry anyway nothing gets investigated
John Coughlin covers things up and it
goes all the way oh there's white out
all over my court orders and the
Department of Justice won't investigate
it thank you so much completely
guys the chair now recognizes Matthew
routhier
and once again three minutes
good morning chair members uh Matthew
Ruth here I'm here in support of this
bill
as a representative Lynn pointed out
um
the majority of the complaints against
uh judges is in the family court I just
did a quick little research from 2017 to
and during that time period
from 2017
uh the complaints filed for Family Court
judges was about 34 percent of the total
complaints
and as of 2021 that is up to 70 percent
of the complaints
I feel that
um this resolution is a necessity
because due process
stands for fair procedures
and part of that is an unbiased Tribunal
the right to present evidence and call
witnesses
and decision based on evidence as well
as the requirement of the Tribunal for
written finding of facts and rulings of
law
that seems to not be the case in the
majority of
uh family court cases if you were to
Adventure if you were to look at the
number of appeals that are before The
Supreme Court
they again would be
based on the fact that judges have not
fulfilled that requirement for finding a
facts and rulings of law
I feel that in my certain case
um
when my case started I had
had to file a motion for emergency order
to have time with my daughter
uh that
ended up in a hearing and then two
months later we were in another hearing
for temporary Waters
as part of those temporary orders I did
not have any increase in time with my
daughter with no findings there was no
parenting plan
provided and these are the type of
things that people suffer
when there is no
accountability you know I believe that
this country again was built on checks
and balances it's obvious that
um
you folks have the ability to you know
do that and with this house resolution
and I feel that that
is a necessary thing based on the
testimony you hear on a regular basis as
well as the number of accounts and
appeals that are filed in regarding the
family court
thank you sir and under time and on
point any questions
seeing none thank you and the chair
recognizes representative J.R Hull
thank you chairman members of the
committee representative hole
representing the towns of Dunbarton
hooks at Allenstown and epsom here to
testify in favor of the bill
um and I want to start off real quickly
there is something called confirmation
bias you see what you want to see right
and there are those who think the
judicial system is broken they'll see it
that way for those who think it works
they'll see it that way and I think we
should take all testimony
right in in light of that your task as a
committee is to look where are the facts
um for the record I'm going to talk
about my personal case we won the case I
think the representative from Windham
made my case made the case for passing
this house resolution
because he talks about we should go look
at transcripts I want to talk about
transcripts I want to talk about things
you guys can't see because of the
confidentiality nature of many of these
cases dcyf cases are confidential in
nature and the transcripts can't just be
read by anybody
at risk I'm willing to read some of the
transcripts from my keys because I think
it's important and I will summarize with
the outcome at the adjudicatory hearing
during the hearing the overwhelming
credible evidence demonstrated that this
statement meaning that I was neglecting
my children had no Medical Foundation
the credible evidence also reflected
that the parents had not neglected one
of my children redacted in any way and
was certainly not in a manner alleged by
dcyf that was the final outcome
I'm going to start back at the beginning
why the process is broken in the first
order after the ex parte order an order
that I was not present because it was an
ex party order could we actually present
any evidence
there was an initial hearing father
agrees to sorry
um wrong line
the scheduling of said hearing shall
account for the availability of the
father's medical Witnesses all of whom
shall be able to testify telephonically
that is the judge's order at the first
hearing that is December 16th understand
the start of December 8th fast forward
to January 21st we have a status hearing
okay
um I want to read another line each side
will have one and a half hours to
present the case including
cross-examination
um
the case will be scheduled for three
hours at preliminary hearing which will
proceed by offers of proof and
cross-examination of the pro offered
Witnesses okay I'm so still allowed to
have my Witnesses
guess what we get to the hearing where
this takes place
and the judge makes a decision on page
83 in this that basically says I've made
up my mind
one of my attorneys the attorney for my
son objects and I want to quote his
objection because it's so clear
um
that there was no evidence presented
from our side during the preliminary
hearing because he did not allow the
medical doctor
the emergency room doctor I was paying
to sit in the hallway at the Concord
Court a chance to testify over a
three-hour window although his first
order said he could be allowed to
testify telephonically
I have a problem with that the system is
broken 15 seconds
um I would encourage you to pass this
bill you never find a problem if you
don't look for it there is clearly
something that is aggravating a bunch of
families at least be willing to look
under the cover of what's going on with
that I'll close my testimony thank you
representative any questions for the
representative
seeing none thank you sir Ed Bryans is
called up next
Mr Brian's welcome
hello uh Representatives my name is Ed
Bryant um I've been coming up here for
almost a decade uh frankly 10 years ago
went through a family court matter
myself
um
I stand with this bill I believe there
needs to be some attention paid to
what's going on in the family courts
um I see it as a few things I believe
the judicial discretion needs to be
tightened uh the low level of evidence
needed uh in Family Court matters um I
don't know if we're at a clear and
convincing or preponderance level but
there needs to be a level of evidence
because in my experience it's based on
hearsay
my situation we had an ex parte motion
filed basically claiming that I was a
flight risk my daughter was pulled from
me on her birthday with my last words to
her being cake friends and presents the
claim was made that I was a Flight Risk
22 months later in my court hearing
after three administrative
administrative continuances there was a
Facebook message to my father who was
diagnosed with stage four cancer I had
told him dad I'd love to come see you
I'd love for you to meet your grandchild
that made me a flight risk
at the point where I did get my day in
court
um the guardian litem was completely
against me her recommendations to the
court were that I have one day a year
with my daughter on Father's Day and it
would alternate on Christmas on even
years the attorney for my ex
um had offered me every other weekend
with my daughter and Wednesday dinner
visits which I believe is pretty
standard with a lot of court orders the
odd thing is as I pointed out to them
being a pro se lit again with no legal
experience
it seemed a little hypocritical to me
that they claim I'm a Flight Risk and
keep my daughter from me for almost two
years but yet they're offering me every
other weekend
I could be anywhere in the world in 48
hours
my my feelings are at the end of my
court case whenever the the guardian
litem would file for a fee increase
I would respond with the motion saying
your honor deny her fee increase in fact
charge her for theft of services
for the money she's already received
that she's not doing anything at the end
of my court case I walked out with 50 50
custody
the guardian items fee increases were
denied
and for 10 years I've been co-parenting
with my ex-wife
my daughter is the captain of the
basketball team she ran for and was
elected School president she benefits
from having both of her loving parents
in her life
it shouldn't have taken two years to get
to that point and during that time I
can't get that time back
I know later on we have a hearing on a
shared parenting bill but I fully
believe that the court system needs to
be looked at between the guardian items
that have quasi-judicial immunity to
where they're immune to any perjury or
false swearing there's other situations
with some of the domestic violence
coalitions that pick and choose their
litigants
um visitation center that I was ordered
to go to
um abused my child
when I went to the police department to
report their abuse the officer that went
to investigate because all the visits
are recorded accidentally deleted the
tape
so there's a lot of problems I sit here
today I benefit in no way from any
changes in rules and investigations
my time with my daughters is great my my
relationship with my co-parent is great
10 seconds Sir
um I do teach a co-parenting class once
a week I've been doing that for over a
year teaching people to how to love
their children more than Aether X and I
hear the same experiences being repeated
over and over thank you so much for
coming before us any questions
saying none thank you sir thank you
chair recognizes Katrina Heinrich
Exeter
she has written testimony she says to
you would give it to representative
Bickford and pass it around and
you know rather than saying 15 seconds
I'll just hold up a card that means 15
seconds I think that's a little nicer I
have to be looking at you though
foreign
hello I'm Katrina Heinrich with over
excuse me a decade in court I'm for
house resolution 14.
thank you to all your members for your
time on this because this is this is a
serious situation
I come before you today to speak about
my experience in the New Hampshire
family court and problems surrounding
due process
while applicable you're not going to
hear me talk about the sociology
psychology criminology or culture
aspects of the harm
and with respect I'm going to talk about
my experience about the problematic
patterns of public policy ethics
structured abuse and financial rewards
during my case
divorce decrees are designed to be final
perhaps on occasion a modification
however 10 years of post-divorce court
is not modification
and Maya children appeared to be the
Pawns
Tethered to the court through
unsubstantiated motions and orders a
theme emerged
no due process
dependent on Rule New Hampshire rule 9
or 2.2
and also dependent on RSA
491-a salaries
case protraction private contractor
rules and failure to enforce statute
the patterns I'm going to talk about
number one is Rule 2.2
The Rules of Evidence do not apply
pattern two the money flow emerged
went from unnecessary gal billing to
unnecessary therapist billing and
establish points of weighted case
calculations as referred to in RSA 491-a
resources were flowing from meeting our
needs
to unsubstantiated need for family court
services
a Hallmark of my case is the pattern of
judicial decisions and predictable
orders promoting more and more hearings
without relief or resolution
the pattern Fosters conflict order show
no concern for myself or my children or
the regard of our basic needs or
well-being
pattern four statute and deadlines
seemed irrelevant written orders would
name people without proper service
notification
the protracted case methodology allowing
perjury over evidence appears to suggest
New Hampshire rule 2.2 is the foundation
of legal workarounds weaponizing the
court
I would refer you to the document
representative Bernardi gave you by
Manchester attorney Shawna Brown
that is was written for uh the bar
article called the truth the whole truth
or something like the truth in this she
clearly understands the perjury and
family court
pattern 5 encompasses a business model
the court model emphasizes creating a
post-divorce issue where there is none
and protracting the case
reasons suggests this court model cannot
exist alone as independent on pattern
six private contractor associations
which would include the GL therapists
and firms that do that do specialize in
divorce services
pattern 7 transcripts that did not align
with what actually happened in the court
it is not that the script
is necessarily wrong it's what's missing
from it
which is typically aligned to judicial
behaviors
upon transcript review alterations
appear to occur in real time recording
control and altered transcripts was
always a topic
this committee heard testimony about in
2022 and 2023
and I noted
last month we were all in this room
January 17 2023
and we are in attendance when we heard
Mr head testify to convey that judges do
not control the recordings there's no
foot pedal control in reference to any
equipment
but he mentioned there was a button
under the desk
and with respect I find this is notable
because in January 16th in 2022
at hearings on this very issue Richard
head gave testimony to approximately 448
to 449
stating and I quote
some of that has occurred he further
stated I quote the judges are
responsible for the recording
he continued explaining that the budget
cuts was the reason for court equipment
in the control of judges
this year on January 17 2023 I spoke
about the prolific churning and
protraction of cases
I found Mr head's testimony notable
Mr had explained to all of us that we
need to understand that someone in the
courtroom for 30 minutes hearing has 20
more people behind them
I interpret that this does not address
protraction issue but in fact confirms
protraction
and I will conclude with a summary
failure and I totally apologize for this
ultimately what you guys do is important
and the patterns of facts and evidence
about Family Court will lead where it
leads and respectfully stating
which are the rights the court never
upheld for myself and my children thank
you for your testimony you're welcome
chair recognizes Anthony Kinney
foreign
first I don't know if you did
yes go ahead representative with a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
on the last paragraph of your uh page on
the last parent and the first page you
say pattern four uh statute and
deadlines seem irrelevant
what is the recourse for that problem
occurring
I think you have to enforce it was that
I think you have to enforce it you have
to enforce statute
like for instance the example I wrote in
there so that I could limit this was
talking about written or I would get
written orders
with people named in it who were never
given
any kind of service notification as
required they couldn't show up at Court
they didn't know about court but here
they are named in these orders
well how are they supposed to be there
to talk oh do you see what I'm saying
there's the statute wasn't enforced that
they have to give proper service okay
thank you
okay now come up thank you so much okay
it's all right
good afternoon Mr chairman
Representatives uh my name is Anthony
Kinney sorry I'm a little emotional here
um I'm a resident of Middleton New
Hampshire
I'm here today uh to testify in support
of HR 14. uh
you gotta get real close real close
okay
um so the little bit of history of my
family case a couple years ago when the
petition first went in uh visitation was
withheld I submitted a ex parte motion
uh which the other side had an attorney
and I didn't
um in both the uh the judge and the
attorney had requested that there was
two motions to be denied
um that brought us to a temporary
hearing where the my rights to my son
were already starting to be taken away
on on allegation
and so when I found out there was a
conflict of interest with the attorney
and the judge I had asked him to accuse
himself
I'm only here today uh
because I waived my due process rights
to to be heard by a jury
and I withdrew my appeal
I just finished serving 60 days Carroll
County House of Corrections
uh it was a full sentence uh judge
Greenhouse sentenced me on a bench trial
or allegedly sending a non-threatening
text message about parenting my 10 year
old son to his mother
after judge green I'll issue an order
restraining me from no contact I was
arrested for sending another text
message after he accused himself due to
conflicts of interest
but they didn't find uh didn't stop him
from uh Finding Me criminally guilty and
sentenced to 60 days even after the same
complaint was denied by a different
judge
when I tried to appeal to Superior Court
for de novo
uh the judge ordered me reincarcerated
uh preventative detention until I Was
Heard by a jury
for the same text message I withdrew my
appeal and my right to a jury so I could
be released
to spend time with my son because he
doesn't understand why the Court's doing
this
so
if a family court judge doesn't like you
they can lock you up throw away the key
and if you stand up to them
for no other reason than trying to
parent
or trying to assert your constitutional
rights
I urge you uh as far as the subpoena
goes I would like to have some of my
questions answered
and uh as far as an investigation
I do disagree with one side prevailing
we shouldn't be in competition for our
children for 15 seconds
and so if anyone has any questions I'll
be happy to answer them
about what happened to my family seeing
none thank you so much appreciate your
testimony the chair now recognizes Dana
Albrecht
good afternoon Mr chairman for the
record my name is Dana Albrecht from
Nashua many of you have heard me before
I'm gonna joke I'd like several hours
but we don't have several hours and
that's precisely the point of why we
need an investigation to look into this
more fully what we do have is countless
victims of the circuit court system
that's currently presided over by chief
administrative Judge David King
and all those victims including myself
deserve a full investigation and some
method of redress
uh to address some of the things the
representative from Wyndham said I would
strongly urge you all to look at the
handout I said around it's only three
pages what you've got there is an email
from Judge King about the misconduct
uh and what you've got after that is
what the JCC did about it which was to
dismiss it
um
even now the New Hampshire judicial
branch refuses to release the complete
and unredacted deposition of Judge King
related to their own internal
investigation of that and again to
address what the representative from
Windham said about order the transcripts
I think that's a great idea how do we
order the transcript of Judge King's
deposition
and that's why the subpoena power of
this bill is so important because in a
family law case where there's proven
misconduct shouldn't it at least the
children and family law committee or the
house Judiciary Committee be able to get
a the deposition of the chief
administrative judge directly relating
to that misconduct and see what they
think about it
and um
again I could do several hours but I'm
going to leave it there all these
victims including myself and all this
testimony you've heard deserve a full
investigation in some method of redress
so please pass this resolution thank you
thank you any questions
seeing none again thank you so much sir
and the chair calls Gail drobat
good morning
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the opportunity to testify
before you today
for the record my name is Gail drobat I
reside in Amherst New Hampshire
in full disclosure I have not myself
been in Family Court
I have advocated for many parents
um
this is a horrifying system
abusing their children
um
is judicial officer and Office of the
Court take an oath to uphold the U.S
Constitution the New Hampshire
Constitution and the New Hampshire State
Statute laws Each of which supersedes
the rules of the family court
rule 2.2 application of the New
Hampshire Rules of Evidence the New
Hampshire Rules of Evidence do not apply
to the actions listed above those rules
that statement supports the Court's
already predetermined cases of a winner
takes all custodial parent
relegating the other fit parent to an
every other weekend visitor
the waiver of these rules and denials of
constitutional fundamental liberty
protections denies children frequent and
continued contact with fit parents with
no finding of abuse or neglect
when you turn a very important Court
Family Court that is supposed to be
protecting the rights of children into a
business model and deem it a court of
equity you lose sight of what is
supposed to be protected
the most vulnerable of our society the
children
the business Equity model wastes the
financial resources of the parents by
way of ordering unnecessary court
involved Guardian ad litems therapists
and any other court Affiliated
professional to financially reward their
peers leaving minimal resources to
provide and care for the basic needs of
their children
the systemic abuse of discretion and
denial of due process will have lifelong
detrimental consequences for innocent
children
children do not do not get a do-over
they do not get to rewrite their
childhood and the damage caused by a
system that is in place to protect them
the denial of due process judge is
routinely not reading pleadings
decisional delays not holding hearings
or producing orders in a timely manner
going into hearings ill-prepared not
recognizing who the moving party is
fabricated orders that are factually not
true made on perjured material
misreference representations
um
not holding a hearing for 11 months not
addressing original pleadings not
addressing mental emotional states of
children
15 seconds to wrap it up there there's a
clear systemic abuse of discretion lack
of due process denial and constitutional
rights Supreme Court protections and New
Hampshire law throughout the New
Hampshire Circuit Court Family Division
at the expense of innocent children
removing fit parents from their lives
contributes to every societal ill we
face today thank you so much for your
testimony if you have handouts
start at the end and he will distribute
them the chair now recognizes Laurie
obadaro did I get that right
no I read better this way
thank you for coming
okay and and to show you can multitask
push the button on the mic perfect great
Okay Lori ortolano I live in Nashua I've
never been involved in family court so
I'm speaking as an outsider but I'm
speaking as an outsider that has some
knowledge of what some of my friends and
my sister-in-law went through and with
their encounter in Family Court I think
that if we peel away you know any
language that involves corrupt judges
because it's an uncomfortable place to
go and we just focus on process there is
plenty here to look at to look at
process Improvement and I think it's
very important we do that
you know these are very emotionally
charged cases and family court is where
you're going to see the highest level of
emotionally charged cases but we have to
be careful that we're not dismissing
these complaints and allowing potential
bad conduct to exist in plain sight
because they are emotionally charged
cases we have to look and we have to be
attentive to that court rules super
important and I think you have a great
opportunity to understand the rules and
gather data my sister-in-law was
involved in gaining custody of two young
children through that anise had in
providing support she lives in
Massachusetts she's been a psych nurse
for 40 years she's been involved with
child issues and guardian ad litem
issues in Massachusetts her statement to
me is why doesn't New Hampshire try to
improve the system and operate a little
more efficiently like Massachusetts does
because after spending thirty thousand
dollars trying to assist these kids she
wanted to pull her hair out and they're
raising these two young children she's
65 and her husband is 70. it's a huge
commitment and she has a very loving
heart she's all about the kids she's
worked with children her own whole life
so I think there's an opportunity with a
neighboring state to look at process
down there as well
deadlines very important the judicial
system as a whole does not acknowledge
there's no regulations or laws that
mandate when orders have to be issued
and The Honorable representative from
Windham mentioned that you know a lot of
complaints get filed by people who lose
I just filed The JCC complaint on a case
I won and I have a call at one o'clock
with an AOC director to address a
clerking issue in the court I won but
I'm complaining because I thought the
process was completely wrong and it took
seven months to get something that
should have taken 30 days so I'm
sympathetic to what these parents are
saying and I see children and families
that are going six eight and ten years
waiting for orders and parenting plans
to be determined it's too long it's too
painful and there's too much trauma
involved in that so these stories could
go on a lot longer I can tell and I
think it's worth allowing them to be
explored and to go on a little longer
thank you very much and thank you for
not going on a little longer I really
appreciate what you did there that's
good the chair recognizes and I'm trying
to read red on pink Michelle leguminous
that's my fault not come on up say it
again
where's it from I'm sorry what where's
the country it's from uh Canada
it sounds Canadian okay
again my name is Michelle lagimonier
um it is a bit hard for me to be here
today because what I'm going to speak
about is is very real and it's happening
right now but it's important for me it's
important for me to be here
um I'm in favor of HR 14. the failure of
due process is very present in my
current divorce case
um
I am living in a hostile and offensive
environment
my mental health has been impacted
there is a cycle of violence that was
going on in my household
I walked on eggshells
my husband's language made me feel small
inferior and belittled
it was to the point of abuse
and it was a very volatile and
difficult environment in my home
um
I've currently spent about fifteen
thousand dollars that I don't have
in this divorce case
I am trying to get my word out when we
have court cases
and I haven't been able to speak
what I want to be able to say
I've had roadblocks put up
I've been accused of things that I
haven't committed
and I'm trying to advocate for my
daughter who I have concerned about and
it just hasn't been able to happen
I've been fearful of my husband for
quite some time
I have used avoidance tactics to stay
away from him
everything appears in all intensive
purposes to look okay but it's not
um
my husband
I believe has a mental health disorder
but because I wasn't able to get it in
the divorce proceeding at the proper
time in the proper order
it's not acknowledged
um
so again I am here in favor of H.R 14 I
do feel it's very important
that's it thank you so much thank you
for your courage to come before us as
well chair recognizes Vivian Gerard
thank you chair and members of the
committee as I had told you guys in the
past I have been to the Supreme Court
four times actually five appeals four
times with the remian coming back to the
local courts so I am a winning case
um I know representative uh Bob Lin said
that it's only the people that are
complaining that that have lost I am not
that person I won every single time for
full child support to my children I did
have two bad judges I had intercasso and
delbro that both showed very much so
unethical Behavior I did file JCC
reports nothing ever came up at the
beginning
um in my case in Picasso did she did not
allow evidence to come in or allow
motions
um to come in late from my ex but I was
not able to um go ahead and put in late
motions on my side as
I needed to I got blindsided I was
biased against from these judges I have
a 10 inch binder that I did not bring
today but I've brought it here before
that shows all the judge's discussions
on my case
the judge allowed evidence there are a
lot of evidence when they feel like it
or excluded it as they felt it was
critical to that case and in many times
it actually had led to very profound
disadvantages to me and as I had spoke
to you guys this morning about the wage
assignments that showed many in many
cases that the monthly obligation amount
should not have changed the only thing
that was in dispute was urea's based on
all of these um Supreme Court appeals
every time something went through the
court it took at least six to nine
months each time a order went through
the court system for one particular
order it would take 25 months from the
time the order came out to the time it
actually went before a judge and and the
judge turned around and said no I am
staying to this order and those orders
were passed out to you this morning
so the the timeliness between these
events are too damaging to families and
the fact that judges are supposed to
have 30 days to communicate back to
people like me of why it's taken so long
and what is causing the problems on
these orders
and from my understanding in my case the
judge is supposed to go to judge king
and let them know what has taken so long
on these orders granted in my case I
have had a long nine-year divorce I've
had five appeals for them that got
remanded for the judge to turn around
and say that I didn't deserve child
support for my children 15 seconds
absolutely I just think it's a disgrace
and I believe it's all feeding into this
ecosystem that is provided and and it
goes between the schools the judges and
everywhere else so I just think that
this is a very good bill to support to
look into these ecosystems that are
being fed by our ATMs May the chair say
Well done thank you this was good this
time
and rep not representative I wouldn't do
that attorney Richard head
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Richard head I'm
the government Affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch I do want to put
into context
um sort of the
um no more pink cards we are closed
after this person
um what is Family Division so in and I
talked about this before but
um we don't have a family court per se
we have Family Division we have probate
Division and we have District division
all are part of the court that we're
talking about which is circuit court and
circuit court judges hear cases in all
of those divisions so we don't have
judges that just here
they're not just hearing Family Division
cases but they're hearing the broad
scope of them and within the Circuit
Court what we are what we have is about
000 new cases coming in every year so we
have 127
000 cases all new coming in each year
and to handle that we have 42 full-time
judges and six part-time judges it is a
overwhelming workload and and sort of my
my point of bringing this up is some of
the changes that are being implemented
currently and what our chief justice is
currently doing towards trying to bring
some some relief to what is a very
stressed system so
um within this year's budget from the
judicial branch the the chief justice is
asking for additional resources in the
Circuit Court I'm just going to focus on
the circuit court and he's asking that
we have seven additional judges into the
circuit court and and put some numbers
to what that means last year or last
year we did what's called a weighted
caseload study with the national Center
of state courts and what they did was
evaluate how much time is spent by
judges in all of their cases very
broadly stated
the chief just did this presentation in
about two hours I'll do it in another
minute
and what we know is that the total
number of Judges that we have adds up to
what's called a session day is the
amount of days that a judge can sit and
with the judges we currently have we
have available
249 session days
um I'm sorry that's for each judge so
each judge can do 249 we have a total of
about 10 500 session days in our system
with our judges so that's sort of the
number that we have if you take up the
total time that all of those cases take
for for those judges
of we have 10 500 available
it requires sixteen thousand three
hundred to get through all those games
one minute left thank you
um and and what we're doing through the
to the chief Justice's budget is adding
to our judges so we can add session days
so we can bring some relief into the
system separately we have similar
stresses in the court clerk system we
are bringing in and we've asked for and
the chief justice has asked for 31
additional staff clerks within our court
system to help relieve some of the
backlog within the clerk system I could
go on there's there's simply a great
deal of stress in the system and what
you hear in what you heard today some of
the issues being length of time delay
and uh and trying to get cases moved
through
what this bill would do would as as
representative Lynn said essentially
recreate what was in 2011 the redress of
grievance committee where where
individuals can come in talk about their
case from a very one-sided perspective
this adds into it the ability to issue a
subpoena to a judge to come in and talk
about case decisions they may even be
cases that are live before that judge
currently they may be judges or cases
that are on appeal they may even be
cases where the court is not issued in
order yet and come in and have to under
oath under a subpoena testify about the
uh about the very cases that they are
evaluating and deciding with that I
understand my time is up I would be
happy to answer questions or answer
questions on the side if anyone has any
thank you for your time seeing no
questions this uh closes the hearing on
house resolution 14 we will reconvene
for an exact session at 120.
120 I suggest I have suggested that
representative Lynn and whole and
Bernardi and former representative Itza
and probably my vice chair and anybody
else
come to see where we can pluck out some
good stuff of this resolution and take
into account the other aspects of it
maybe we can square the circle not sure
I'd like to see if we could try thank
you
be seated
foreign
all right
upcoming uh upcoming testimonials has
nothing to do with the executive session
this is an amendment to
opening the executive session on a
number of bills just to uh remind those
who may be new to this an executive
session is not the second part of a
hearing
don't fill out pink cards you will not
be called upon
the chair occasionally will call on
somebody for a clarification if we're
having a discussion and we don't
understand something at my discretion I
may call upon a person for a very brief
clarification
also
members of the committee and seat
fillers
if you leave the room
when the question is called
and you subsequently return you cannot
vote and calling the question is like
this here's the motion before us House
Bill 789 the motion is ought to pass
moved by representative Smith seconded
by representative Jones with the clerk
please call the roll that's calling the
question if you're not in the room for
that little speech and you walk in later
you don't get to vote so we will try I
will try to Signal
the occasional courtesy break that we
might meet
all right
open uh opening the executive session on
House Bill 306 relative to prohibiting
reunification therapy
you looking for discussion or are you
looking for a motion the chair is going
to move to retain
and who seconded representative
to see you
I mean it's not unmice to see the others
but you weren't here so
so chair moves retain
um seconded by representative Moulton
anybody wish to enter into discussion
we thought that there was some good
things in here but it was a little
generalized in its language and as we
continued to bat it around you may
remember we thought that if this bill
were retained there could be some good
work done on it and it could be brought
up in the fall for this work session
with then a vote which will send it to
the floor of the house in next January
any further discussion on 306.
the motion before us is
retain
moved by The Chair seconded by
representative Moulton
the clerk may call the roll
Jim and Pearson
yes
representative long
I oh okay
representative DeSimone
representative Bigfoot yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes
yes representative ball
representative panic
out of the room okay
representative Grossman
yes representative Levesque yes
representative Petrino will be voting
yes representative schuette
representative Greg yes representative
Moulton yes representative Raymond yes
14-0
oh I'm a yes
I apologize representative Seidel I just
skipped right over your name
yes
and yes she figured you fix you thank
you
alrighty that does not need any reports
to be written because we are going to
keep it in the back pocket to take out
in the fall and that is when reports uh
will be written
excuse me Mr chairman What's the total
vote please 14 that that's the clerk
14-0
all right
all right next up it doesn't have yes
okay
uh next on the calendar is
um
that concludes whatever we just did 306.
okay now open the exact session on House
Bill 535 requiring an attorney for a
child and so on uh I have one Amendment
before me is there another amendment
that is being presented
foreign
we have one Amendment entitled zero six
one one
that's found in the upper left corner
but is there another amendment that has
been worked on and given to a member of
this committee to present
all right
the chair will entertain a
motion
um
with the amendment on it
and that will be Representatives Seidel
will do this to make up for your being
inadvertently ignored previously what is
your motion thank you Mr chairman um Mr
chairman I would wish to move uh House
Bill 535 with Amendment
0611h the motion is move House Bill 535
with amendment 0611 is there a second
yeah I was saying thank you
but he didn't say it she didn't
you didn't I guess I did not uh to pass
would you like to I would I thought so
thank you
it would be an otpa now let's take a
look at the amendment
remember we had numbers of questions
that came up and
I assume that representative hole has
addressed those
let's take let's take a minute and read
through it
foreign
all right are we ready to discuss
representative Moulton thank you Mr
chairman um so I have some issues with
this bill
um
the the original Bill I'm not talking
quite about the amendment yet doesn't
necessarily say that the child's
expressed interests
um are in
where so if the if the child's expressed
in interest conflict with the
recommendation from the guardian ad
litem but my issue with that is that
sometimes kids don't know what's in
their best interest
so which is why they need adults to make
decisions for them
um if they could always make the right
decision then they wouldn't really need
parents and in in this case they
wouldn't need parents for money
well
um so
for example if I can use my teenager for
a for an example that you know if he uh
if he you know made a mess and so I any
and he didn't clean it up and I gave him
till a certain time frame to to clean it
up and he didn't and so I you know
turned off his cell phone for the
weekend or something like that he that
might that's a most people would say
that's an appropriate punishment but
that would be against the child's
expressed interests and so because he
would want to keep his phone but also
not have to clean up a mess because he's
a teenager so
um so my issue is that
sometimes child children you know
I don't think that it would be
appropriate for an attorney to get
involved just because a child's
expressed interest is in conflict with a
guardian ad litem I think I think
there that opens up a can of worms
I wonder if lines 2234 help us that the
the child can wave that off in other
words the child could fire the attorney
If the child wanted to it's not demanded
it's not it's just giving the child
another resource the council would
counsel
maybe say you don't want to do that
I think
it could be
anybody else
representative Raymond
uh thank you Mr chairman
um and thank you to representative hole
um who has put quite a bit of work into
this
um making the amendment and bringing it
back to us I I see a lot of the things
that we had discussed in this amendment
and I really appreciate that
um I also see some of the concerns that
Casa had are addressed by this amendment
as well and I appreciate that I'd just
like to highlight there are some
significant changes in this amendment
from the original Bill some of which I
think are really great and others I'm
still concerned about the language so
under line 9 2A it says the court shall
appoint an attorney to represent an
Indigent parent alleged neglect or abuse
his child I cannot express my support to
that enough I worked for dcif back in
those years when parents didn't have
attorneys there was like two years or
they weren't being appointed attorneys
and it was terrible everyone deserves to
have
an attorney giving them advice so I
agree with that completely B online 16
is great
um C it says on the date of a point of
filing the court shall appoint an
attorney to represent the child's
expressed interest for children 12 years
or older I appreciate that there was an
effort made not to give you know six
month olds and two-year-olds attorneys
as a matter of wrote Because we all
agree that that's probably not people's
best choice but there are circumstances
where those kids might and this allows
for it so I appreciate that
um but I'm concerned about section
number 21 to 25 regarding letting the
child essentially wave having an
attorney I don't know that a 12 year old
who gets mad at their attorney should be
able to waive that advice they can say
I'm not going to follow it
um but that worries me and the other big
concern that I have with it is we
haven't done any kind of research to
find out where this pool of attorneys is
going to come from and I don't see
anything in here
about who's going to pay for these
attorneys and I don't want parents to be
unnecessarily burdened with additional
legal fees and I don't want our system
to have unnecessary backlogs if we
simply cannot find attorneys who are
let's assume willing to do whatever the
rate is that the the state decides I'd
really like to see this bill still
retained a little bit longer so that
there can be some sort of an
investigation
honestly I would put it in the office of
the child advocate to find out what
where are we in our attorney situation
what's the Staffing levels like what's
an appropriate compensation what are our
neighbors doing for compensations for
this and where is this money going to
come from to pay for these attorneys I
really hesitate to rush into appointing
attorneys to kids when we don't have a
mechanism financially to pay for it
without
burdening parents further and I I just I
can't get my mind around the financial
impact yet but I can see myself getting
there if we have a financial plan which
unfortunately still isn't attached
so
let me speak a little bit here and that
may because I think it may dovetail if
you go back to lines 18 to 20 of the
amendment
um shall appoint an attorney to
represent the child's Express's interest
turn to the next page
and look to line two
line two says this section will kick in
July 1st 2025.
the reason that is there I believe is
multiple number one it gives the bar
association two years to learn how such
appointed attorneys to children would
function
it will be not in the budget cycle we're
working on now but in the next budget
cycle at which financial questions about
this I believe could be addressed and
the the third one about what other
states do we have a mechanism in the
oversight Commission on children's
services who can do exactly that finding
out what other states do and when it
works and finding out still other states
where maybe it didn't that we could
learn from so I think some of those
questions that that were very wisely
raised I think they they have some
answers to them representative D Simone
thank you Mr chair I wanted to talk a
little bit about the representatives
concerns and rightfully so however we're
the policy committee and this is in
early bill because it will go from here
to finance and finance will figure out
who pays how much they pay when they pay
where they pay and so so forth so for
this bill we're really supposed to be
looking at what's in front of us which
is the policy of the bill
and I I don't know if that will help the
representative with her questions or not
representative long
thank you Mr chairman I I wholeheartedly
agree with representative Raymond
um you know the fact that this is
extended to 2025 tells me that it's not
ready
um I I I agree with uh attorney
appointments I mean I I received we all
received ncaa's
um uh latest study I believe it was uh
and and from what I got out of reading
that 70-something pages is the
importance of training so where are we
going to get the attorneys it is is a is
a good point because with that we'll
come training for trauma-informed
attorneys to use with these children
um you know in fact in 2025 that this
kicks in uh in 2025 where where we're in
finance drafting a budget so this kicks
in when there isn't a budget yet
we don't know where the money is coming
from as of 2025. uh has a January of
2025.
um so uh
I I you know I
hasn't B and C 16 and 18 uh you know the
May and then the 12 year old uh you know
there were some seven or eight-year-olds
or nine-year-olds even so I I so I want
to be sure that we're helping
the the children that need the help
um
in my mind supporting this in my mind
would be
um
better than nothing and and I don't I
don't want to be better than nothing I
want to be what we believe is the best
interests of uh these uh these children
thank you representative Bickford
uh thank you Mr chairman
um I
have the same issues that uh
representative Raymond last brought up
in about
uh
mostly uh about who's paying here but
I don't think we should
pass this bill or try to we might
actually get a count of
10 11 but we need to get something like
this that looks as complicated as to the
uh the full assembly
uh we need a pretty good vote so I'm
going to recommend that we
consider withdrawing the motion of ought
to pass and go with the retain
because I think we could polish this up
so we get
most of the whole committee on board
that's what we're going to need to get
this thing through to the Senate
representative welcome
thank you Mr chair
um I just wanted to point out it was
stated that this was an early Bill
however I believe it this is not an
early Bill well that's what I was going
to say if it was it had it was supposed
to be on the calendar tomorrow or
Thursday this is not an early Bill thank
you
representative Moulton thank you Mr
chairman uh if we're discussing some
other changes that we might want to
entertain with polishing this up
um
I I agree with what representative
Raymond was saying
um for the most part uh for the vast
majority but also online 18 uh the child
who is 12 years old or older at the date
of filing that
see I mean I realize like a lot of
things happen when a child is 12 but it
also seems a little bit arbitrary to
pick 12 as opposed to 10 as opposed to 8
as opposed to so I would like to see
maybe and and I could be the one to kind
of look it up especially we're retaining
in this this in committee and we could
come back to it later
um see if they're you know what other
states have on file for for that age uh
see if there's some research available
for what age uh
but unless there's
evidence that 12 year years old is the
is the time where a child should have
the attorney like maybe
we want to amend the wording to give a
little bit of leeway you know an 11 year
what's wrong with an 11 year old you
know what's wrong with it
it might be a little bit Case by case
specific
um so we would want to put language in
that for there
um
and we might want to pick a different
age
okay
we have a suggestion that we can act on
and that is the suggestion is would the
sponsor and second wish to withdraw so
that the bill could be retained and
further worked on along the lines of
what was suggested I'm not calling for a
vote I'm just calling for a kind of a
sense is this something we might want to
do your head's pivot up and down or left
to right
laughs
I'm just looking this is not a hint
I always
what do you think you you made the
motion I I be satisfied with with
retention with trying the OTP
ad you have to withdraw your motion okay
okay now we have no motions on the floor
and the chair will entertain a motion
oh
she can't see me
I have a motion
I did I need one of those little upsies
well you know I could pick up my cane
and like thump it or something I don't
know that's tacky and you are only
adjacent to the Rowdy section you are
not in it so
okay go thank you Mr chairman I move
that we retain
um HB 535 oh do I have to say the
amendment number
what's no no because now it goes back to
the original Bill oh I don't but I like
the amendment mostly
if we retain it there's no reason why
the amendment language cannot come back
in its Glory with even more improvements
okay yes that's what I would like to do
so I move that we retain HB 535 please
and you'll never guess what the check
chair needs right now
thank you
any further discussion
now the word retains has two meanings in
the dictionary for us one means death
With Dignity we hate it but we don't
have the courage to say so
or it means we're going to keep it and
we're going to work on it and we're
going to take counsel with each other
and we're going to run back and forth
and make this until you know everybody
stands up in cheers that that's what I'm
hoping this is okay anything further of
discussion on the motion which is
retained
moved by representative Raymond second
and by representative Bickford
it recognizes representative Moulton
thank you Mr chairman for for the
freshman in the at the table
um when does something that's retained
come back is it something we work on
during the summer we can work on it
during the summer into the fall we will
have a meeting of this committee
sometime in the fall to pick up two
already retained and it looks like maybe
a third one in others and we will work
on them and we will vote on them and we
will make our recommendations and you
will write a wonderful blurb and then
early in January we vote on it I see
okay thank you welcome
um along the lines of
what she just pointed out we used to do
uh subcommittees along the way and now I
notice we're not doing that so much I do
know that retain usually gives us more
ability to look at than a subcommittee
is that the idea usually it's this
chairman that appoints a subcommittee
yes purposely doing it this way rather
than subcommittee I'm not purposely
doing anything right now except try to
get a vote but um what I would be
interested in is
um in a week or two I will announce the
different bills we've retained and ask
of you which ones you would like to be
on a work group of
well it doesn't answer my question but
okay I know that
all right I have called the question
and now the clerk may call the roll
the motion is to retain
chairman Pearson yes
Vice chairman long yes representative D
Simone
representative Bickford yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
Seidel yes representative Grossman yes
representative Levesque yes
representative Petrino yes
representative shewitt yes
representative Greg yes representative
Moulton yes representative Raymond yes
and that's 16 yays
zero Nays sorry
add that to the retain
pile
next
and this will close the exact session on
houseboat 535 and I open the exact
session on House Bill 471 relative to
final disposition hearings in divorce
proceedings the sponsor of this bill was
representative yokella
chair would entertain a motion
foreign
representative ball
for a motion yes I'd like to make a
motion that we OTP
um house bill 471.
all right yes the motion is OTP by
representative ball do we have a second
who said second second representative
Panic second
discussion
representative long
thank you Mr chairman um I I certainly
understand the need for final
disposition hearings given people uh
Reliance on this will end in some time
but I I believe that this bill has
written is a false sense of a final
dispositional hearing uh that that I
don't believe this changes anything that
we've been hearing in testimony
um coming before us so
um not in support of the ought to pass
representative Greg
and I second that that you know you're
welcome oh no then I would but
representative longsen but thank you Mr
Chuck
um sorry I cannot remember that part I'm
usually better with manners
um you know divorces are complicated as
we all know whether you've been in one
or not but I think that what this bill
is wanting to do which would be to help
streamline it and make it more
predictable I think it's actually going
to have a catastrophic backswing the
other way
um the reason being is that you might
have one divorce that could take like 30
days and then you have another divorce
that could take years the problem is if
we have to set if the judge has to set
dates as soon as these come in and you
don't really know whether or not you
want to try to reschedule it later or
anything else let's say you're the first
in the year but they have 6 000 cases
well by the time you get to the end how
many years off are you setting some of
these divorces that could have been 30
days all of a sudden you have one that
could have been quick but because they
had to set dates ahead of time now all
of a sudden you're pushed out years
because all these dates are filled and
then saying okay now we're gonna we had
a cancellation you're on a cancellation
list to come in earlier I think it
actually further complicates the court
system
thank you representative Raymond thank
you Mr chairman
um I I share the same concerns as my
colleagues this morning we heard a lot
of really moving testimony on um another
uh issue on H.R 14 and in part of that
testimony it sounds like there's a
general consensus amongst people
involved in family court and certainly
with the judicial branch itself that the
family court is taking
um a significant amount of time to
resolve some of these cases and so I
think it's laudable to try and come up
with Solutions but what we heard today
is that they have 127 000 new cases each
year and only we're done 42 full-time
judges to make all that happen so I know
that they're requesting additional
judges in this coming budget year and a
significant number of additional clerks
and I I would urge us to see how
additional Staffing assists and get
staff onboarded before we start
requiring scheduling of things because I
just I really hate the idea of someone
coming in and filing for divorce and
then hearing that their final hearing
isn't going to be for 24 months because
I'm afraid that if we pass this now that
the the court is going to err on the
side of well this is our next free day
for you know to schedule these things
because we have to keep open time in the
meantime for the other 126 999 cases
that we know are coming so my feeling on
this is that now is not the time
here
representative Moulton thank you Mr
chairman the other
uh unanticipated consequence that that
we might end up seeing with if if this
bill was executed as written
um I know in my case we had a temporary
Hearing in
October and they gave us the date of the
first day after January 1st which came
and went and we and and it never
actually came to fruition so we might
end up finding that in order to meet the
the rules of the of the statute that
that judges are just throwing out these
dates and not actually like meeting them
because the dockets are so full so if if
they're not actually coming to fruition
then it's then it's a useless bill
so
thank you representative ball
I believe the purpose of the bill is to
you're welcome I'm sorry I'm terribly
sorry
I choose my poor manners chairman
Pearson thank you for recognizing at
least it's bipartisan thank you
I don't normally speak
um anyways I believe my understanding of
the bill was
um pretty much to get the people
um into the queue because it is taking
so long so rather than having them work
on their divorce situations and then
decide okay well let's get on the docket
and then find out the docket is a year
or two years out when they've already
lost
however many months
and I believe that in testimony they
were also saying that as we keep people
hanging and waiting and waiting uh in
limbo to get onto the docket it causes
more damage to the minor children who
are going through the trauma of the
parents who continue to fight it's
costing the families more money because
more emotions are being filed tensions
are getting higher and a lot of that is
just from frustration in waiting to have
their court case heard
foreign
I'm trying to peek into every corner
anyone else nope representative Bickford
sure
um I too am not ready to go forward with
this bill apparently because they it it
gets under divorce it should be broader
than divorce but the main reason
is
um
we heard from Richard head that there's
a real serious problem with getting
cases and such
uh on the docket in the right place
and I believe they're trying to do
something about it I talked to judge
Legend finance and this this is a seems
to be a money issue with 127 000 was a
thousand or yeah I get lost the numbers
so high and and I think I'm not ready to
jump in and start tinkering with the
Machinery of the court and this is what
this is this is about tinkering with
their system
and it doesn't mean it shouldn't happen
and I may be completely wrong at this
point but I'm just not ready to jump
jump in
so I
um
I'm gonna have to vote no on the ought
to pass
thank you anyone else
the motion before us
representative panic
thank you
um chairman I do have an eye doctor's
appointment on Friday I missed you I'm
sorry
I just got my new glasses how they're
doing I can see you now so the eyes have
it yeah
[Laughter]
is there a way that we could
move to on to pass under the condition
that we try and get more judges no
just asking good idea thank you we're
trying to get more judges believe me a
lot of us are trying to get more judges
I'm not going to law school after all I
was afraid they might pick me and I
don't want to do that I like this
uh no anyone else
and I don't think this is one of these
bills that if we retained it for six
months we could Square the circle I
think it's either we we say it or we
don't say it I'm not sure if there's a
middle place is there right you can of
course however I'm looking forward to HR
14 to help resolve some of these issues
and as I said I talked to Judge Lynn
about coming in with an amendment for
that one and seeing if we can stop being
a get together on these issues and go
from there but meantime in the meantime
yeah you can but it I don't think it's
going to buy it a whole lot
now Last Chance seeing no other hands
other than representative ball
thank you chairman Pearson I I would
like to just point out that um
in testimony it was told that in
Criminal Court that everything is
scheduled right up front and I I just
question as to why in in divorce
proceedings that the parents or the the
two parties that are seeking to and
their marriage aren't given the same
courtesy even if it's scheduling out 24
months at least they have an idea of
when they're getting out of court rather
than just kind of languishing there and
just in a state of limbo of not knowing
what's happening how do they plan their
life ahead maybe they want to move on
maybe they want you know it just let's
just let's just allow the court to be
honest with them and tell them when
there can expect that they're have a
final hearing
thank you representative Moulton thank
you Mr chairman um I do think there's
some value in letting some time elapse
uh I
did in my in my personal situation I
didn't see the value in that and I
wanted you know I know what I want to
ask for and you know this is what we
need in blah blah blah But as time
elapsed different issues came up that we
couldn't foresee in the beginning so
having that time elapsed having you know
my my soon-to-be ex and I uh try to
resolve them and you know some things
we're able to get results on things
weren't you know things like that
um the time is a little bit valuable
it's it's frustrating and you know not
having the orders that you want make you
know Muddy's Waters and and things like
that but by
seeing different issues that have popped
up we can get that language into the
final decree when we get it so
I think to answer your question I think
that because with a criminal case you
already it's not ongoing like one thing
happened and that was it you know
whereas
with
child and family you know things are
always evolving and situations are
always you know changing and and stuff
like that
so
representative Bickford
um I just happen to think that the
advantage of a retain would be that this
could come back next year if we don't
retain it we have to wait two years for
it to crop up again
um
anyone else
then I'll call the question the motion
before us is on House Bill 471 FN
relative to final disposition hearings
in divorce proceedings moved by
representative Ball seconded by
representative Panic the motion is ought
to pass when the clerk is ready please
call the roll
chairman Pearson
yes
representative long no
representative DeSimone
representative Bickford no
representative Nelson yes
representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
Seidel yes
representative Grossman
no
representative Levesque no
representative Petrino will be voting no
representative schuette no
representative Greg no representative
Moulton no
representative Raymond no
OTP fails
729 chair now entertains we have to have
a positive dispositive motion chair will
entertain a second motion
itl
representative Bickford
are you making a motion to retain
that is in order
does anyone wish to Second the retain I
second it all right
any further discussion
representative Moulton
thank you Mr chairman
um I'm not sure what value retaining
this would have
um I mean either they can clear the
dockets and and you know hire more
judges or or promote lawyers to judges
or or they can't and that's a
complicated issue so uh I would
be can I would be concerned that that
retaining it isn't going to help
fix up the language to to make this uh
bill that could actually be executed uh
so I personally would be in in favor of
it yelling it but but the motion on the
floor is is to retained so
we should defend your retain you you
were going down a line of thought there
a minute ago on this right well my
reasons for retain is if we should learn
in during retain
that the court really hasn't done their
job
the way they should and we feel that
they can be directed by the legislature
we would be able to come forward next
year I think it's in January usually the
retained bills are acted upon or we
could just at that time let it go so
there's no
that's the advantage you gain a year if
it's useful
gosh
um even the rowdies are quiet
yes representative I'm here now
um thank you Mr chairman
um so I'm just wondering how what would
we
if we retained this what would you
suggest
um that we would do just call each
individual court and and ask them like
like survey them so to speak about what
issues are are the stop block on the
docket but we would have to call every
single like Court in the state
um I'm just wondering just in good
asking in good faith what how we would
find out this information
why I start by thank you Mr chairman by
going back to
um Mr head
who comes to here for the court system
and then you'd ask him if you couldn't
interview some
people and you may want to take some
statements from uh other people which I
think will just show up anyway
I don't expect it would take a lot of
uh time maybe a couple meetings and then
you'd sit on it
wait and see
representative long
thank you Mr chairman uh we just heard
an H HR 14 which is going to look at all
this stuff and what representative
Bickford's alluding to that if we retain
this we could bring It Forward then in
January if we itl it it won't come back
for another two years so there may be a
fix
that we could work that we could put in
good language for this uh so that's
that's that reason so I'm going to
support the retain retention
also I always go looking for what do
other states do do other states have
this kind of thing they have people with
problems and judges on benches and so on
and what do they do and
um I hate to say uh I will ask my
research committee research assistant to
do it but I know she will thank you
you have until September
anyone else
motion before us is moved to retain
House Bill 470 1fn relative to final
disposition hearings and divorce
proceedings moved by representative
Bickford seconded by representative
Panic please call the roll
Jim and Pearson yes
representative long yes
representative DeSimone
representative Bickford yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
Seidel yes representative Grossman yes
representative Levesque
yes representative Petrina will be
voting yes representative schuette yes
representative Greg yes representative
Moulton yes representative Raymond yes
retained carry 16-0
16-0 there is no reports that need to be
written the work will happen at a much
later date the motion to retain carries
ends the uh
exact session on 471. I now opened the
executive session on House Bill 479 FN
relative to the confidentiality of
Records within the division of children
youth and families and the chair looks
to representative Panic for a motion
I motioned for ought to pass
thank you and do we have a second
represented is
representative disamani
discussion
Mr chair yes can I just make a
correction it may make a correction
House Bill 497 not House Bill
479. did I last Dixit that
apparently so apparently so 497.
foreign
thank you for the correction
discussion on the bill
representative Raymond should I go up
instead of out I don't know
yes
thank you thank you Mr chairman
um I cannot support this bill
um I don't see that anybody has
submitted an amendment and my concerns
remain the same that they were when it
came before us a few weeks ago so
um the this bill basically is making an
allegation that dcyf is not providing
families with records the way that they
ought to be and we received significant
testimony that already dcyf is required
to give parents their records but they
have to submit a request and then they
have 60 days to do it however dcyf
doesn't currently have the staff to
always meet that 60-day thing
furthermore we learned that if you have
an open assessment that has not had a
finding made unfounded or founded you're
not going to have the records and if
there is a case where the police are
involved you're not getting the records
then either because then you're obstruct
acting a case that the police are doing
and nobody wants to get involved in that
so this is a bill that seeks to
solve a problem without really getting
to the basis of what the problem is or
if there is a problem the last reason
that I'm going to oppose this is that I
think that part of the
um the germane point of the the bill was
to try and access other records so if
your child or your family is involved in
tcyf dcyf is going to collect records
from the schools from the pediatrician
from
um you know a therapist anyone that a
parent signs permission for dcif to
access records from dcyf is prevented
based on HIPAA from re-releasing those
third party records there's literally no
way that dcyf can legally give you what
the pediatrician gave dcyf if you want
that information you need to go directly
to the pediatrician or to the school or
to the therapist and then you have a
right to have it because you're the
parent so I think that
um
again I really think this is a bill
um based on someone's personal
experience where they didn't feel like
they had a good experience and now
they're trying to legislate based on one
example and I just don't I don't think
that's an appropriate use of our of um
of our committee time or legislative
powers so
anyone else with a comment on the bill
seeing none
the motion before us
is ought to pass
on House Bill 497 relative to the
confidentiality of Records within the
division of children youth and families
moved by representative Panic seconded
by representative D Simone will the
clerk please call the role
chairman Pearson yes
Vice chairman long no
representative DeSimone yes
representative Bickford yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
Seidel yes representative Grossman no
representative Levesque
no representative Petrino no
Representative schuette no
representative Greg no representative
Moulton no representative Raymond no
the vote is eight to eight it comes out
of the committee with no specific
recommendation
there needs to be uh on the OTP side
someone to write the blurb
who would like to do that
that's those of you who voted yes
a committee report has to be written
from both sides representative long work
your side of the room
um
itl
I just assumed I was being volunteled to
do that and that's fine thank you Mr
chairman Vice turban
I'm
okay
representative Panic will write the
OTP motion and representative Raymond
will write the itl motion
not motion report committee report good
Mr chairman yes can we go back for a
second to
um House Bill 306 we voted to retain we
did uh and is it can
can we put that on consent
no it doesn't go oh it doesn't go there
thank you I'm sorry it goes in my back
pocket thank you for correcting oh hey
come on we all helping each other out
here you know you
untwangled my numbers a minute ago okay
this uh concludes the um
executive session on 497 and with that
opening I will open the hearing on House
Bill 185 FN relative to the
determination of parental rights and
responsibilities based on shared
parenting and shared access to the
child's records and I believe
representative posts will come forward
on that
let's find my folder
.
your testimony points well can we just
get two yeah
take my mom and write those out
and believe it or not this bill has the
correct exploitation you're kidding
that's the likelihood of that let's say
the chair is going to be passing around
an amendment by the Bill's Prime sponsor
and the reason I do that is not that we
can necessarily vote on it unless we
choose to go into an exec session but
because very often the bill is
originally written I had a journey on
its way to us and this will give us at
least a chance to see what the prime
sponsor is is thinking so that's why
you're getting this
um
of paper
Mr chair
but if I may I will take my leave
I will take my leave now it was a
pleasure to serve
thank you
on another bill
the chair recognizes representative post
thank you very much for the record I am
representative Lisa post serving
Hillsboro 42 that is lineboro Mount
Vernon and New Boston my thanks to
Chairman Pearson and the committee for
the opportunity to introduce house bill
185 relative to the determination of
parental rights and responsibilities
based on shared parenting and shared
access to the child's records
this is a constituent bill that was
authored by Gail droback and she is
excuse me drobat she is here today to
testify
um on on her behalf she is is the author
of it and she has worked on this bill
for a very long time and I will defer to
her
on the questions regarding herbel
I come before you today
to improve the lives of children and
strengthen Society by protecting every
child's rights to the love and care of
both parents after separation or divorce
Mr chair I believe you'll agree with me
that this bill has been before this
committee and house many times over the
years and many legislators have come
before me with similar bills that have
passed both the committee and the house
but never made it into law
permitting the court system is not
working for children who do not have
regular contact with both parents and I
think you heard in HR 14 this morning
a woman named Linda who was talking
about the process the process is broken
it takes too long and it leaves families
in a very bad state
uh
the child's best interest is to have the
benefit of both parents and our
constitution provides just that
children's rights are provided by their
parents power and duty to protect the
health
education and well-being of the child
there is a growing and compelling
consensus among researchers that true
shared parenting is usually in the best
interest of the child
moms and dads have different talents
skills and approaches to life and this
creates a diverse environment for the
child to learn grow
and be confident under the care of their
parents
our laws should be clear and concise
that no parent should be denied the
ability to execute their Duty and power
to protect the rights of the child
regardless of separation or divorce
several states have recently passed
legislation beginning with the
presumption of joint custody which is in
the child's best interest unless the
courts find there is an abundance of
clear and convincing evidence of abuse
and neglect and that is something that
um
they are using the language in so that
the courts really dig into what's going
on
my hope that this is the year of the
child to thrive with both parents in
their lives and I ask for your support
in passing House Bill 185 to protect our
children and support our New Hampshire
families to live their best lives
Mr chairman I am not a subject expert
and I would request a defer questions to
others more knowledgeable than I but if
you have a question that you think I can
answer not being an expert I'm happy to
do so
foreign
thank you so much and the chair
recognizes the aforementioned Gail
drobat
um actually could I have
um Karen uh calabra was here she's a PA
and she can testify uh to that
um on how the effects of children we'll
get to her okay thank you she does have
a time constraint at three o'clock so
thank you
well I'm who is
oh you didn't have a pink card oh sorry
I will certainly
what is the name I didn't put in a pink
card
this is my first she she didn't put it
in okay first
she'll fill one out okay you can forge
it okay okay so the chair recognizes
state representative
my name is Karen Calabro
um District Hillsboro 45. okay welcome
there's only like 6 000 of us here so
that's why
um I am I'm speaking on behalf of the um
as primary care provider to the homeless
um I got to see a lot of people kind of
falling through the cracks I see a lot
of families that are undergoing a lot of
upheaval unfortunately it is my
population and it is very oftentimes the
people whom you are talking about
um the number one thing that I can tell
you as a predictor of failure is a
disengaged parent
um whether it be through geography or
through financial means or through
um
by choice
a lot of them have addiction issues and
and whatnot that'll oftentimes keep them
from it and that would make good sense
but assuming that these people have an
interest I have seen more fathers
squandering waiting to see their child
then I care to count
and their sobriety is on the line
waiting so that they can have that
stability
so I'd ask you to consider the spot
thank you thank you chairman
and I thank you for your time do you
have any questions
how soon before I get the pink card
[Laughter]
any other questions
it's very good thank you thank you
representative now the chair gets to
call Gail drobat
mentioned as a Prime
source for this
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the opportunity to testify
before you today
for the record my name is Gail drobat I
reside in Amherst New Hampshire and I
come before you today in support of HB
185. as our elected policy makers you
have the greatest ability to create
create and reform outdated laws to
better protect the children of New
Hampshire
I am before you respectfully requesting
your support and passing this much
needed legislation
HB 185 is to protect the children's
rights this bill will allow children the
right to equal access with both fit
parents this may be rebutted with clear
and convincing evidence that it is not
the best interest standard each parent
brings valuable meaning and lessons to
life the lives of their children
children have fundamental Liberty
interests in free association with both
parents the court cannot act in a
child's best interest if it fails to
protect the child's fundamental
liberties
judges are deciding fundamental rights
of children and making life-altering
decisions that will impact their lives
forever
New Hampshire chapter 461a parental
rights and responsibilities A2 States in
part and codifies that children do best
when both parents have a stable and
meaningful involvement in their lives
it goes on to State unless clearly shown
in a particular case it is detrimental
to a child that the state will support
frequent and continued contact between
each child and both parents
the standard orders are typically a
custodial parent with the majority of
parenting time and a non-custular parent
relegated to an every other weekend
visitor this does not constitute
frequent and continued contact with each
child and both parents these rights are
already presumptively in Statue HB 185
codifies 50 50 shared parenting which
may be rebutted
if it's not the best interest Decades of
social science research favors the
closer to equal time a child has with
each parent the better outcomes for
children this bill will allow an even
playing field parents knowing going into
separation of divorce the child will
have equal access with both parents they
will no longer be litigating Petty
grievances or making false allegations
of abuse or neglect to gain the upper
hand in court proceedings less
litigation frees the overburdened
dockets from unnecessary litigation
I believe it is the appropriate time to
pass House Bill 185 we need to legislate
good policies that work for most
citizens this bill does still protect
children from abuse and neglect
and that is in our statue already
thank you
thank you for your presentation and all
the hard work you're doing chair
recognizes Mary Krueger
from the New Hampshire legal assistance
um thank you Mr chair and thank you
members of the committee my name is Mary
Krueger I'm an attorney at New Hampshire
legal assistance we're a Statewide
non-profit Law Firm providing civil
legal services to low-income clients and
seniors
um to meet their basic needs we also
operate a domestic violence advocacy
project where we represent clients who
have been screened in for a high
lethality domestic violence cases those
are the kinds of cases where there's a
likelihood that someone could be killed
we do
protective order cases and we also do
divorce and parenting cases I'm here to
oppose hb185
um my colleague Aaron Jacina did
circulate some written testimony in
addition to
um an article from The Battered Women's
Justice project to also talk about this
issue I'll just highlight that a main
reason why a parent may stay in an
abusive marriage or relationship is to
protect the children and for fear that
the children will be taken away from
them if they do leave the relationship
because that's often a threat that's
used to control a victim who's
abused in addition to financial control
and sometimes the courthouse is the last
place where an abuser can exert that
control and manipulation that fear that
a victim may have for their own safety
and their children's safety may cause
them to decide to stay together if a
bill like this passes what where the
presumption is equal parenting
that could just cause them to remain in
that relationship for fear that their
children will spend
time with an abusive parent the current
law where we the presumption Is frequent
and continuing contact is has worked
really well since
2005. I've been to this committee
several times I've worked on a
commission or a committee over the
summer to make some tweaks to that
parental rights and responsibilities law
in order to ensure that really frequent
and continuing contact is the policy
that's stated in the law we've inserted
it into a couple of other places
including in the best interest standard
that currently is in the law and so
courts are very aware of that the other
thing that is concerning about this is
it creates clear and convincing evidence
as a standard currently the standard for
a court to determine what's in a child's
best interest in terms of parenting time
is preponderance of the evidence and
that is like a lower standard clear and
convincing evidence is a higher standard
and it's very unusual in the Civil
context to be utilized so it's harder to
demonstrate improve and what I see this
doing is as it is it really undermines
the ability to analyze what is in the
child's best interest elevating a
children's rights over parent rights and
this is a parental rights and
responsibilities law so this committee
really needs to think about the change
in the policy that it would set in
adopting something that elevates the
child's rights above a parent's rights
which it potentially could do and is an
interesting Dynamic that I hadn't
actually considered until I sat and
listened to the the testimony before me
so I those are some of the reasons I
would caution moving forward with this
um and I'll happy to take any questions
my question is you would not have this
before you it was just given to us but
would you believe that in the amendment
uh rebuttable is evidence of abuse
including evidence of abuses defined and
it gives several rsas or criminal
assault or abuse so the idea of
co-parenting if one parent may be an
abuser is specifically
rebutted here
I haven't seen the amendment and I'm
happy to take a look at that um and and
you know provide for their testimony on
that
um the concern is the clear and
convincing evidence standard as well and
I think that that really
um elevates the ability for somebody
who's already
um having a hard time articulating you
know because of trauma the the kind of
abuse and the effects of it and whatnot
representative Moulton thank you Mr
chairman
um
so
my my question is with the clear and
convincing evidence they don't just take
Word of Mouth for evidence right you
need like you need photos of of abuse or
some type of documentation of financial
abuse or something right uh if if my
understanding is correct so
say something happened you know 10 years
ago
and the and the parties are like one one
party's being more contentious during
the divorce you couldn't be able to go
back in time and say oh well you know
they they're abusive they've been
showing abusive patterns because that's
not clear and convincing evidence is my
understanding correct
um I mean somewhat I think you would
need to have more corroborating evidence
which is what I think you're you're
talking about in addition to somebody's
testimony I mean testimony is very
powerful evidence in in a case of
somebody's experience
um but the corroborating evidence may be
required which is hard to come by when
you have
um domestic abuse that is often behind
closed doors and so you often don't have
the advantage of having other witnesses
to have seen
um you know what's occurred so I do that
is a concern what is also concerning is
that we've never used that standard for
for deciding what used to be called
custody in 2005 we we replaced all of
that language for a reason because we're
not talking about children as property
anymore
um but that's a standard that we've
never used and it's very unusual in a
civil case to use that standard
um you know that I can't even off the
top of my head think of when that
standard comes into play in civil
matters
thank you
representative Raymond
thank you Mr chairman and thank you so
much for taking my question what is the
current standard in family court cases
when we're talking about
parenting time or allegations of you
know domestic violence or other
allegations it's a preponderance of the
evidence which means more likely than
not
and under 461a
throughout it references RSA 173b or
um the child abuse statute those two
statutes would that the court would use
those statutes to Define what
constitutes child abuse neglect or
domestic violence
um and that you would have to prove by a
preponderance of the evidence that there
was domestic violence or child abuse or
both present in order to
um you know
help the court to understand or decide
that there would be something other than
frequent and continuing contact the
Court's also looking at the safety of
the the abused parent the safety of the
child in both and the effect of the
abuse that that might have on the child
so it's not like a done deal if you
demonstrate that there's been domestic
violence that under RSA 173b that
there's going to be something less than
frequent and continuing contact you
still need to demonstrate why it's not
in the child's best interest to have
that contact with the abuser parent
follow-up follow-up thank you Mr
chairman
um so for people who aren't
um you know frequently in court and get
most of our information about court
cases from like television what's what
is the significant difference that we
need to know about the difference
between preponderance of the evidence
clear and convincing and then the
criminal statute of Beyond A Reasonable
Doubt like how do I put those in line in
my brain so that I understand
where each one falls on a Continuum of
evidence sure so preponderance of the
evidence is like the easiest burden of
proof it's more likely likely than not
um Beyond A Reasonable Doubt is the
highest standard you know for a criminal
case where if there's any doubt then
you're not guilty so this is sort of in
between those two it's and that's the
best way I can describe it I think
there's some subjectivity to that but
that's the best way to describe it
thank you
no further questions thank you for your
testimony the chair calls Dana Albrecht
good afternoon again Mr chairman for the
record again my name is Dana Albrecht
from Nashua
um I'd actually like to begin by just
rebutting a couple things I heard
earlier
um
I think right now the in practice in
these abuse cases the plaintiff is
presumed to be right with no notice to
the defendant until somebody shows
otherwise and I believe also in practice
and some of these abuse cases we let in
multiple levels of totem hearsay so
they're really in practice isn't an
evidentiary standard
and so these statutes can be used as a
weapon in uh whenever you have
reciprocal hostility between divorced
parents in a high conflict case
uh particularly with the amendment I
think this abuse addresses the abuse
very clearly nobody is saying that an
abusive parent shown to be abusive
should have 50 50 nor does this bill do
that and so I think we're chasing a red
herring with the abuse issue
uh with that said I would just say our
state has lofty ideals
empowering rights are protected under
Article 2 of our state constitution we
have case law describing a spirit of
equality that pervades the entire state
constitution the reality on the ground
with parenting is that's not the case
um jumping ahead to testimony we heard
earlier
we've got 127k backlog of cases we've
got overworked judges
I've sat through a five-day parenting
hearing not my case where we're arguing
about
whether a cold leftover Chinese food
is being litigated and that's stupid
you should come into court and a judge
should ask do we have an agreement and
if the parents have an agreement we're
done now we're off the 127k date
docket
and if the answer to that is no then the
judge should say can anybody give me a
good reason why I shouldn't award 50 50
parenting time
and if the answer to that is no
congratulations we're off the docket
gets rid of the backlog
and if the answer to that is yes
then somebody should start talking one
of the two parties with some valid
reasons and whether the evidence you're
standing at that point is preponderance
or clear and convincing you know you can
exec that out
um but if we just have a presumption
that this is how we're doing it absent a
good reason to do otherwise we can clear
the docket and I would just finish that
this would have gone
a long way towards preventing the
tragedy of my own case
and to address what other states are
doing what other states are doing right
now
you know California Michigan multiple
other states is trying to figure out
what New Hampshire did in my case
and
because we didn't get it right from the
beginning
and if we just have this I wouldn't be
in a six and a half year protracted
court case and so let's pass this and
just make it easy and clear the docket
that happy to take questions any
questions
seeing none thank you see one thank you
representative Moulton thank you Mr
chairman so are you for or against this
I am absolutely for this you're for this
okay thank you
thank you for your testimony the chair
recognizes Attorney Richard head from
the judicial branch
thank you Mr chairman thank you members
of the committee my name is Richard head
I'm the government Affairs coordinator
for the judicial branch
um
what my comments are are really into in
in drafting comments
um so for example
um
and I'm talking about the bill is
introduced and I did
um I was I was uh I was able to get a
copy of the amendment and I have a
couple thoughts on the amendment I think
the amendment is an improvement
um in terms of of drafting
um but on the original bill on lines
four to five it references in accordance
with the best interests of the child
pursuant to our say 461 a colon 2 1A
that's a very narrow
um definition of best interest of the of
the child if if that was to be used
um 169
a21 a
is excuse me
um simply says support frequent and
continued contact between child and both
parents that's not the full definition
of best interest of the of the child
and really that should be a reference to
RSA one
um 461 A6 which is the definition of
best interests of the child
in most of the rest of of the first part
of section one and the amendment it
references equal parenting time so we
have a lot of words in 461 a we have
decision making responsibility we have
parental rights and responsibilities we
have parenting schedule and we have
residential responsibility we do not
currently have equal parenting time so
now we have a new phrase that's being
introduced in into the mix of things
we all may say well we know we all know
at equal parenting time that's sort of
obvious if we all tried to write down
separately what equal parenting time
means that might be something different
and now a judge is going to be
interpreting that there is no definition
contained here uh as to what equal
parenting time means so for example
Concord school district has 177 days in
the school year so that sort of tends to
get
boxed up with with one parent or another
depending on their their geography you
know what does it mean when we're
talking about equal parenting time as
compared to parental rights and
responsibilities or when we're talking
about residential responsibility because
one of the statute one of the rules of
statutory construction is well we're
using a different word so we must mean
something different it's not clear what
it is we mean when we're when we're
using that that particular word
um and we already have sort of policy
goals that are stated in 461a we support
frequent and continued contact we want
to share the uh we want the both parents
to share in rights and responsibilities
we want both parents to have joint
decision making and those are in the
best interests of the child so this just
adds another layer without a lot of
definition
um
in the bill is introduced which I
believe is if I'm reading it correctly
and the amendment is taken out which I
appreciate I think is a very good move
on page two of the bill is introduced
lines 4 through 12
talks about access to records and what
happens if access is denied and it says
upon on line seven upon the written
request of a of the parent the court
shell upon its finding that the
individual professional public and
private institution organization has
denied such requests without cause order
that party to stop doing stuff and to
award fees that is not a party in the
litigation it's it's somebody who is
external to the court and this would
require us to make findings to somebody
who's not involved in a proceeding in
front of the court that is not something
the court can do and then sort of they
don't have an opportunity to present to
talk to do anything but orders are being
issued again them apparently without
their knowledge I believe that is that
is corrected in the amendment by simply
dropping that part of it out
um
in uh in both the amendment and the bill
and I'll talk about the
bill as introduced
um
lines 14 to 15 talks about if you go to
the introduction the presumption that
equal parenting time per calendar year
is in the best interest of the child may
be rebutted
and then 14 and 15 says if one of the
parties does not request sole primary or
joint responsibility for the child
that at least I have some troubles
interpreting exactly what that means
when we're talking about equal parenting
time but one of the parties simply does
not request sole primary joint that
appears to be a rebut to equal parenting
time and truthfully I'm just confused as
as to exactly how that would be applied
in in terms of of a court trying to
interpret that language
um
and with that I would conclude my
comments but be happy to answer any
questions
any questions representative Nelson
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um
is there any way we can find out data on
how much time presently is awarded like
um I don't know exactly how to word this
question but um so we don't so okay yeah
you probably know what I'm I'm asking so
so thank you for the question we do not
in our database have a way of extracting
out orders of of time awarded so it we
don't have a database that we could
extract that from simply because that
data is not inputted into it we know how
many cases are filed we know
um you know some limited data but we we
don't input all of the data from an
order into into our database so then we
can't extract it okay thank you
representative DeSimone
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking
for tea tree
defined equal parenting and what that
means
um so thank you for the question I did
not look I only looked at the New
Hampshire statutes to see if there was a
definition I did not look if there are
definitions around the country and if
they're the same
thank you
okay
representative Bickford
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr Ed
um
in
we passed
presumption in favor of shared parenting
rights
uh bill you know one of the differences
was do we use the definition of
comparable instead of equal use the
words comparable would that be
helpful that passed the committee four
to zero went on the consent calendar
I I think the if if you use the same
words that we've used before those tend
to have had some some time to be
interpreted I'm not sure exactly and I
apologize exactly what change you would
be proposing
you instead of equal you would say
comparable yeah utilizing the word
comparable as opposed to equal that's
that's the difference I can see
between the two bills in 2005 and the
one now
um and yeah truthfully
um I would have to think about it I
haven't looked at the I haven't looked
at how comparable has been interpreted
in that context I and if I may I'd like
your remark can I have your written
document of your remarks and I've got
script I'll take some copy pen scratch
notes notes well can you do them over
that and submit them to the chairman for
us to review I can certainly try because
I thought you had a lot of good
information in there I know I'm happy to
try to put it into a into an email today
committee appreciate that
representative ball
thank you Mr chairman
I am admittedly new to all of this so I
would just like to question since the
there seems to be a
um not able to Define equal is there a
reason why we just don't say 50 50
parenting so so thank you for the
question I I think the you know
conceptually equal means equal and I
understand what equal means does it is
it everybody has to have the same number
of hours is it time spent with the child
but not necessarily residential who's
keeping track of the time so if
you know equal is is a great word
equal what is it is it you know it's
probably not residential time because
that's just already sort of in the
statute as something we're supposed to
aspire to it's you know it's is it
what's the other word
um
oops
hold on I've lost my place now I have a
clip that's my problem
um is it so we we already have sort of
parenting schedule parenting time
um frequent and continuous contact and
residential responsibility so if equal
is supposed to be essentially
are we talking residential
responsibility so that we're equal time
in in the in the respect of homes
okay that's that's fine if that's what's
meant just say it uh if it is time spent
with with the child okay then then I
think just say that and then sort of how
do we measure that
um
or is it something else and I don't know
what the something else would be
um but I think it's just a question of
saying what are we what are we making
equal what's the what what's the math
formula look like to come up with 50 50.
follow up follow up so if this was
clarified to say equal time with parents
and not that other frequent visiting if
it said these are the options you either
go to a five two five two schedule or a
um two two three schedule or so that we
know that in a month of 30 days it's 15
days you're with Mom and 15 days with
Dad and how mom and dad decide whether
you're going to go every other week or
whether you're going to make up time
in the summer or but somehow
the days of the year are divided and you
spend equal amounts of time when you
look at the overall year
um if it's at all possible because then
when you I guess when I look down and I
see where it says what you were
questioning about unless one party says
they can't do it and they're not looking
for that it could be that that person
lives out of state they're working out
of state or for some reason can't take
it on so I could see where what that
would mean but
are you saying that the bill would be
good if we could just Define that one
um equal parenting what exactly is that
sure thank you for the question and and
whether you define it or not the
question is whether you want to have
control of that definition or if you
want that to sort of evolve over time
um with the court system they're going
to have to Define this because there's
not something more specific in in the
bill
okay thank you very much representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman and thank
you again for taking my next question
um with that being said about
um struggling to fund a definition of
equal time what is the definition of
frequent because that's that's not a an
exact measure as well so how does the
how does the court determine exactly
what frequent is
um so thank you for the question I
truthfully did not poll or look into
that before coming here today so I don't
have a I don't know off the top of my
head
seeing No Hands hearing no voices thank
you for your testimony I think you'll
look forward to that transcription from
chicken scratch
chair recognizes The Honorable Betty gay
foreign
thank you for taking my testimony as a
person who's extremely concerned about
domestic abuse and how it is handled in
court
I may sound unusual in that I really
support this bill
for multiple reasons currently there is
no requisite requirement for a judge to
consider domestic abuse or even any
other reason why somebody should not
have parenting rights uh a protracted
Court hearings have been reduced in the
states that have adopted equal shared
parenting they have been reduced over 50
percent in fact in one state if they
have actually
an entire Law Firm
that hired many people has gone out of
business
this this promise is to save parents a
huge amount of money
once you stop fighting about that's the
main thing I'm sorry I can't speak well
but I'll just try to get my ideas across
um that's really what mostly people uh
protract their their legal fights over
is their children the most valuable
thing we have is our children
uh so once you settle that
um
there's not a lot more to fight over
with the great reduction in charges of
domestic violence this also frees up our
agencies that investigate domestic
violence so that they have more time to
investigate the ones that are are much
more serious
one of the things that I was really
concerned about was how do you prove you
know how do you prove there's domestic
violence
um currently like I said under current
rules we all know hard Tails where it
wasn't even considered
the judge just decided that one person
would get a hundred percent of the of
the um
of the custody and they didn't have to
consider the whether that was safe or
not so worse came to worse they would
give a child to a domestic abuser 50 of
the time right now it's happening a
hundred percent so the burden of proof
that isn't some esoteric thing out in
the clouds there's some genuine concrete
ways that you can determine whether a
parent is not safe for a child to live
with and that there's a history a
history of crimes and assault and DV
that's that's recorded
um you can read court documents to see
if there's uh conditions like um is
there a place for the child to actually
stay with this person
um is there safe housing
uh are the or the parent have they ever
shown any kind of behavior that sounds
like they really aren't aren't up to
Priority
um
then there's also medical records
because if this person is an abuser
there should be some medical records
because they've hurt somebody
um I'm kind of Riley amused at not being
able to just discern what 50 50
parenting is
coming from a mathematical background my
background is engineering
equal
is 50 50.
so I really think that's not hard to to
determine and it's nice to give the
parents some flexibility to figure out
how to do those 15 days per month that's
fine we don't have to tell them exactly
but we have to say that is the goal
so I appreciate very much your attention
thank you representative and are there
any questions
thank you I do not see any so thank you
very much and the chair recognizes Ed
Brian's
thank you honorable committee my name is
Ed Bryans I'm from Marlboro New
Hampshire
um I respect this committee's time
um I'm so happy to hear some of the
people of Representative gay going over
the drop in domestic violence claims
from the states of Kentucky West
Virginia and Arkansas that all have a
shared parenting bill
um they're lawyers and judges can now
address issues that are real
I want to
teach this committee a couple coin
phrases that some of us that have been
through the system use one of them will
be called false domestic violence claims
the Silver Bullet the Silver Bullet is
when a claim is made parenting time is
taken away from one person or the other
and it sets the pace for the final
outcome of a hearing
the other uh coin phrase we we use is
being a Disneyland Dad when a father who
is fit for every other weekend to visit
with his child
only has four days a month with that
child you don't spend that time working
on a child's homework uh teaching them
discipline giving them chores normal
things that a father maybe would do but
instead you want to make that four days
a month as enjoyable and fun with that
child and you're gonna allow it you're
gonna spoil the kid so you end up
raising a spoiled child
um again 10 years ago I went through a
family court matter
um the end result was 50 50.
um here I am 10 years later with a 15
year old daughter that I am so grateful
to share time with her mother because
boy she has a lot of drama
um but we don't at this point look at
she stays an extra day at Mom's house
she's got a sports event she doesn't get
back till late you know it's 59 41
percent and maybe 30 percent one week it
may be 75 percent another
but the the fact is is that the mother
and I communicate
and we do what's best for our child
going into the family court Arena that's
exactly what it was it was drag all the
dirty laundry all the most negative
things we can find about each other
because the system is set up to be a
winner take all
and he that wins the prize has the child
um I'm very different than my co-parent
my ex is very organized very methodical
I may be a little bit more adventurous
um
my daughter is the best of both of us
I've been involved a little bit with the
political Arena my daughter surprised me
one day
um put her name in and ran for and
became the school president she's the
captain of the basketball team
you know I'll take my daughter to a rope
swing her mom's oh no she's going to get
hurt but she's adventurous she's strong
she's determined but she's also
organized like her mother
so if it wasn't for that 50 50
I might have the wonderful child that I
have and I just hope this committee will
support this bill and finally see it go
forward
thank you so much for bringing that to
us today does any Committee Member have
a question
thank all of you thank you so much thank
you this will conclude the hearing on
House Bill 185 let me just mention two
of the committee and also to any Bill
sponsors who may be out there we this
committee will not be meeting next week
but we will be meeting on March 7th and
we will exec all the bills we've heard
today and all the bills that we have
heard in the past that we have not yet
exact so therefore if people want to
write amendments and do this is and
that's the exact session is two weeks
from today
now the chair um
opens the hearing on House Bill
455 relative to creating a new state
cause of action and special findings for
abuse neglected abandoned children
seeking special immigrant juvenile
status under federal law the chair
recognizes
representative Laura to less
on sorry I know that I was you were
there I'm fading fast here but thank you
and I think you you want to tell us
where you what you'd like us to do with
this Bill thank you for our conversation
so thank you thank you Mr chairman thank
you committee for having me today I'm
going to start my name is Laura tolerski
I'm represent Hillsborough 11 which is
nashua's board 8. I'm going to start
right off by telling you that I have
communicated with the chair and vice
chair
um that I hope the committee will
consider retaining this bill
um to learn more about the issue I know
that the language is written in this
bill is not going to solve the problem
and I think that can save us a whole lot
of time here if we just take that bill
and uh
stop looking at the text but just use
this opportunity to learn a little bit
more about special immigrant juvenile
status and what the problem might be so
I hope you can um
take a minute to listen to me while I
give you a little bit of background
about how this came about and then I
know that there's people who are going
to be testifying after me
um unmarried citizen non-citizen youth
under the age of 21 in the U.S can be
classified under federal law as special
immigrant juveniles Congress created
this classification for vulnerable youth
who have been abused neglected or
abandoned by one or both parents or
their guardian and whose best interests
are served by not being returned to
their country and instead remaining in
the care and custody of the nominated
Guardian
sij classification and protection has
been available since 1990 when Congress
passed a law to assist these youth with
obtaining lawful permanent residents
through a special immigrant Visa this
classification itself does not Grant
citizenship or even lawful residents
and requesting this Federal
classification as a two-part process our
own state courts are step one since it
is the purview of the states to
determine whether a child has been
abused neglected or abandoned in what is
in the best interest of the child
pursuing this status requires a Judicial
determination regarding the necessary
criteria without the state court
determination a youth cannot seek the
federal law path to sij classification
protection and stabilizing status
after the state court findings are
issued the second step is to then apply
for this sij classification and it is
the federal decision makers who review
the application and make a determination
in other words the federal government
has the sole responsibility to regulate
immigration but certain responsibilities
have been given to the states such as
determinations regarding abused
neglected and abandoned children it is
the state court that must provide
factual findings about a vulnerable
child
why did Congress give States this
responsibility
because the protection well-being and
determining the best interest of
children is directly in the Wheelhouse
of our state courts
it is important to remember the New
Hampshire courts are not giving these
children immigration status
notwithstanding New Hampshire state
court determinations regarding
dependency or custody of young
non-citizens they can still be denied
sij classification but it is the federal
immigration authorities that will deny
or accept the special immigrant juvenile
petition not the state
Congress defers and relies on the states
to make findings regarding dependency
and custody of Youth and appropriate
State Court proceedings through which
these vulnerable youth May seek these
findings
so that's the background
since learning about this issue and
drafting the bill I've met with several
immigrant attorneys and Advocates and
every one of them agrees that state law
Provisions are needed to provide for
appropriate proceedings and
determinations for these vulnerable
youth and the new statutory provisions
and modifications must fit within the
New Hampshire framework
also since this bill was drafted
information has come to light concerning
issues arising in the adjudication of
these matters for minor children within
the existing framework in New Hampshire
as well as an increased scrutiny at the
federal level of orders issued in cases
for older Youth and for these reasons
and to allow more clarity to come of
these issues it seems most prudent to
retain and revisit this legislation in
the fall or again in a future year
so why should we care about this issue
there is some inconsistency among New
Hampshire judges in consideration of the
cases filed on behalf of these
vulnerable youth some judges issue
findings While others don't see it in
their Authority
children particularly those in the group
are the most vulnerable and are at risk
for further abuse and Trauma and run the
risk of homelessness prostitution forced
labor or trafficking and we fail them by
not protecting them
I appreciate the time that the committee
has given to the support and issue today
I believe you will hear from others who
may have thoughts on retaining the bill
to look at the issue further in an
attempt to provide guidance and to
provide the structure needed to solve
this problem in our state
thank you Mr chairman
would it be possible for you and the
other members to get us copies of
documents so that as you know things
wind down here in the spring we'll be
able to open up our folders and start
reading through what you have so when we
have a day to just get everybody
together and have some fun with it uh
we'll be pre-informed a little bit sure
I think you'll hear from um different
parties that uh may be interested in
being part of that conversation any
questions for representative soloski
um representative DeSimone please pass
two of your Altoids down to the
gentleman in the far end
representative bigford
[Laughter]
thank you Mr chairman
um
thank you
I
pretty washed on all this immigration
stuff it's right outside my knowledge
now 21 I see the age 21 in this case and
generally of course New Hampshire we
talk about 18 being agent majority could
you explain that to me a little further
sure that was um part of the question
that we had
um when I was going to file the bill and
um that's some of the questions that
we're trying to work out to see if if
this is the right application for that
so oh okay you can't really answer it no
other than the federal law allows up to
21. okay thank you thank you though
representative D Simone
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question on the same line of
the age of 21. it says here child means
an unmarried person and I'm going to go
back to a bill that we had a couple of
weeks ago and in the state of New
Hampshire uh with judicial and parental
consent you can be married at 16.
not a good idea but you can be by law
so do you really think that 21 should be
the age of an unmarried
person
I'm just uh reporting on the fact that
the federal law allows up to the age of
21 for this immigration status
thank you
thank you representative thank you
chair recognizes Mr Bruno dibrate is it
sir almost Brito
okay this is Portuguese right all right
you got me brother
all right
please sir
you may begin when you're ready by
pushing the button and that activates
the microphone
good all right uh good afternoon Mr
chair good afternoon
members of the committee
um so I have uh provided you with uh a
sheet of paper of uh some uh important
documentation pertaining to special
immigrant juveniles
um I also for some of you
um so you just open your camera uh I'm
sorry because there was a lot of paper I
didn't want to print out a lot of papers
so uh if you open your phone
um you can scan the code and you will
pop up with the PDF so I'm trying to
save you know some trees here but I also
sent it to your emails as well
um so I I know I said I'm going to be
five minutes but I'm gonna be a lot
briefer than that so
um so again my name is Bruno I am a
president and executive director of the
New Hampshire Brazilian Council uh we
are a non-profit organization who
assists uh immigrants and and other
individuals
mainly in the state of New Hampshire but
in all the states as well I am also an
immigration attorney
I my license is active in Massachusetts
um and in New Hampshire uh it's not I
have it as you know like not active so I
still pay my dues
um but uh for for the purposes of a
special immigrant juveniles
um I have a lot of cases mainly in
Massachusetts and they're under the
federal statute
um under their CFR
um acfr it allows anyone who is under 21
to apply for a special immigrant
juvenile
with uh USCIS
um but in order to do that they need a
practical order uh from the state courts
I stating that it is not in the best
interest to uh to return to to their
home country uh that they have been
either abused abandoned or neglected by
one or both their parents and typically
um what happens is uh in the order we
ask the court to either
um to be responsible for that child or
99.9 of the time we asked the court to
denominate another individual such as
the other parent
and typically uh it's the mother who to
continue being responsible for for the
child and
um in the New Hampshire unfortunately
way we are having a lot of issues with
uh getting special findings
um so the the courts they are in
Conflict on how to issue these and uh
some of um the attorneys uh also do not
know how to move forward so we are all
lost uh in New Hampshire on uh how to
get special orders
um here and and this bill I think in
like a representative terlurski is
trying to
um you know take the first step to come
together and hopefully solve the issue
we currently have in the state
so the documents that that I have
provided to you
um the first one the USCIS definition is
simply provides what the definition of a
special juvenile if and
if you also click on the the link it
brings you to to the web page which is
going to provide the same information as
the PDF it's going to show you all the
the requirements for
um the state court orders the
eligibility uh one of the questions was
whether the the person is unmarried at a
state court level
um the state can still issue the the or
the order uh but under uh federal law uh
that would not be accepted but the state
can still issue these essentially would
be a dependency order
um to to that child
um and he also uh the second QR code
States the the purpose of why this law
was
um was created uh essentially there are
a lot of abandoned abused and neglected
children all over the world and and a
lot of these children when you know they
came to this country they didn't have a
say on whether uh you know they wanted
to leave their school in their home
country you know their friends all they
they knew
behind the church or come you know to a
new place
um and you know like a whole completely
uh different life
and the third one uh is the the CFR
which provides the uh the actual
language of the the federal code on what
it is
and uh the the fourth QR code uh at the
bottom
um so it provides a guide from the
American Bar uh um the the American Bar
Association the the ABA it provides a
guide uh for state courts and lawyers uh
across the the country
um and I also have provided a sample of
um the petition of you know like what I
typically file
um in Massachusetts
thank you
any questions
representative disamoni thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question
um how many uh special immigrant
juveniles do we have in New Hampshire to
your knowledge
that is a very good question
um so uh it is hard to to say uh because
a lot of immigrants they they live in
fear so they live in the shadows and
it's a very difficult to give you a
number but I'm gonna give you uh you
know like a number from
um the
um
ah the I forgot so it's part of uh one
of the programs from from the chamber uh
in New York uh it's a new American uh
and I forgot the name of the report I'm
so sorry
um so we estimated that we have uh
approximately 15 000 undocumented
immigrants in the state of New Hampshire
in 2019.
follow-up it is that juveniles or all
undocumented so all undocumented
thank you representative Petrino
thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman would
it be appropriate for uh me to
acknowledge attorney de Brito as a
former student of mine at Nashua
Community College he came to uh my class
with limited English a new arrival to
America he was an incredibly hard worker
and I'm very proud to see that today
he's an attorney uh sitting before us so
yeah thank you
yeah so he actually he taught me how to
read so thank you
anyone else
for representative petrino's prize
students
looking forward to seeing more of you
when we do some hard work on this later
this year thank you sir thank you
chair recognizes Olivia bensonger
good afternoon I think it's still on me
okay great
um
perfect thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee for allowing me
to speak today my name is Olivia
benzinger and I'm an immigration
attorney and other attorney ever at
Shaheen and Gordon here in Concord and I
was happy to have to be able to walk
over here today
um as representative talerski explained
in her opening remarks special immigrant
juvenile status or Siege is all
inevitably call it as I talk today
provides a path to permanent residency
for non-citizen youth who have been
abused neglected or abandoned by one or
both of their parents that path begins
with a determination made by a juvenile
or similar court that the child is under
21 that the child is unmarried and that
the child is dependent upon the court
that the child has been abused neglected
or abandoned by one or both or other
um by one or both of their parents or
another another caretaker and that it is
in the best interest of the child to
remain in the United States
as
the federal government has delegated the
this these responsibilities for the
findings to the state court because it
is within their purview to make best
interest findings
um for youth residents of their states
um and
because these findings are based upon
state law the mechanisms vary from state
to state
the bill presented today has identifies
an issue that presents a discrepancy
between New Hampshire state law and the
federal requirements under New Hampshire
law a child may only be depend dependent
upon the court if he or she is under 18
or over 18 and incapacitated
Federal immigration law defines the
child as anyone under 21. this bill
intends in part to bridge that Gap and
to bring New Hampshire into compliance
with its obligations under federal law
there are many other procedural
difficulties with SIDS that are winding
their way through the New Hampshire
courts right now
um lawyers in the state have been
seeking these special findings through
three primary mechanisms for the past
probably 20 years now
um guarded through guardianship
petitions through 169 C abuse neglect
petitions and through parenting
petitions
and in recent months the New Hampshire
circuit court has stated a firm
preference for the use of the
guardianship petition because it does
not require dcyf involvement like the
169c petition does
um some judges however are not aligned
with the court and finding that they
either have no authority to issue such
findings in a guardianship hearing or
just simply declined to do so
um further guardianship is not the
appropriate vehicle for every case as
some children's need for dependency on
the court varies in form
these jurisdictional issues along with
some service difficulties are the main
obstacles to efficient administration of
these cases in the New Hampshire family
courts right now and this bill does not
address each of those difficulties that
we have that we find ourselves facing
um as attorneys who represent these
clients
um I agree that there needs to be
guidance in the statute on the proper
procedure for seeking these special
findings the this bill attempts to do
that but ultimately presents additional
issues
um in my opinion as it is of
Representative talerski's um it is
in the best interest to retain this bill
for work in the fall or at a later time
there are
as we try to work out through the court
system some of the procedural issues
that are that we're facing with the
courts
um additionally approximately two two
weeks ago and after the introduction of
the bill the USCIS which is the United
States immigration citizenship Services
um citizenship and Immigration Services
sorry said that backwards
um has made clear that bills like this
one which seek to impose a new cause of
action solely for the purpose of
obtaining special findings will trigger
additional scrutiny
um by them when they are reviewing these
immigration petitions after the family
court process and they may not
ultimately provide the protection that
everyone seeks to achieve for these
vulnerable youth
um that is the last thing we want when
it's not the purpose of amending the law
I think representative tolerski for
putting her voice behind this fight and
for seeking to help abused abandoned or
neglected non-citizen youth seeking
refuge in New Hampshire
um I again support these efforts and
hope that we can work them out over
um over the time and into the fall
um
we certainly look forward to working
with the committee to resolve this
discrepancy in the law and working out
the procedural issues we're facing right
now in the family courts thank you
any questions
seeing none thank you counselor
chair recognizes Attorney Richard head
from the judicial branch
remember I would bet the ranch were
going to retain this so input us some
stuff along the way
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Richard head I'm
the government Affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch in light of your
comments
um we do support retaining this bill we
appreciate the sponsor bringing this
this bill forward and and The Advocates
working on it but um and and it's a an
area which there does need to be some
clarification
and we'd be happy to to help with with
work on the bill but in support
retaining it thank you thank you and
Beth Morganson from dcyf available for
questions
so um because this is
use abandonment neglect this is really
not a matter of dcyf's purview in fact
because we're dealing with people over
the age of 18. but uh since the bill is
being retained
um I don't really have any comments
unless you had any questions of me uh
with respect to this to this bill
seeing none thanks for coming okay
now
this
concludes the hearing of House Bill 455
and with the consent of my vice chair
this opens the exact session on the same
so
the representative can watch the bill
retained in real time
chair entertains a motion representative
long
on House Bill 455 I'll move to retain
retain and I would like a republican to
Second it because yeah oh there's a lot
I saw you first representative Nelson
thank you Mr chairman I second okay
second
any discussion
we've already had it
the clerk please call the roll on House
Bill 455 the motion is retained
moved by representative long seconded by
representative Nelson
yes
Pearson
representative long yes representative
DeSimone representative Bickford yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative panic
yes representative Seidel
yes representative Grossman yes
representative Levesque yes
representative Petrino will be voting
yes representative Greg yes
representative Moulton yes
representative Raymond yes motion
to retain 15 to zero
one absent
motion carries 15-0 and this concludes
the exec session in House Bill 455 add
to the pile of retained bills we're
going to be busy this fall but it's
worth it huh
now uh chair opens the hearing on House
Bill 499 uh
uh let me read the title requiring The
Rules of Evidence to apply in family
court cases and relative to admission of
certain evidence in Family Court
proceedings the chair recognizes the
Bill's Prime sponsor representative Holt
thank you chairman I'm going to hand out
two things please
this is the last one for today
thank you chairman members of the
committee representative hole um
speaking on behalf of House Bill 499
relative to rules of Evans and family
court cases and relative to the
admission of certain evidence in Family
Court proceedings
um before you as well is an amendment
2023-091h I will be speaking to both the
bill
as well as the amendment
um between the time it was drafted which
was late December during that hurried
period yeah the bill was drafted during
that hurried time where OAS was trying
to finish up in late December
um the section where this was put into
law was in the judicial rules as opposed
to
and it actually would have created a
conflict with what was in statute under
169 C and the request was really to deal
with
um
having Rules of Evidence for cases
within the dcyf right in the child
neglect and abuse statutes so
um under current law
under 169 C12
there is a carve out and I think I can
read it for you real quick
um
that the rules of evidence do not apply
that's where it goes today
um and part of that is
um maybe there might be a good reason to
not apply Rules of Evidence it's hard to
figure out what to do with a young child
who has relative information now in an
abuse case and dcyf needs to testify on
that
however
um
there should be some standard by which
evidence is presented in these cases and
this bill is intended to deal with 169
C12
okay which I quote in here in any
hearing under this chapter the court
shall not be bound by the technical
Rules of Evidence and may admit evidence
which it considers relevant in material
evidence of Prior founded or unfounded
reports of abuse or neglect shall be
admissible in the proceedings under this
chapter in order to establish a relevant
pattern or course of conduct that is the
current law today
the amendment in front of you actually
replaces all of that
we should have some standard by which
evidence is going into the courtroom
what we have seen is cases where people
are denied the chance to have
information that is beneficial to them
because the judge has complete
discretion
that sets up a non-due process type
process I guess right there is no due
process if all the evidence is slanted
in favor of the state pursuing a
respondent
the next section of this which is two
and this was asked for what if there
needs to be a waiver
um and I drafted in lines 14 and 15 if
the judge has reason to believe that
applying the Rules of Evidence would
challenge adversely affect the case the
judge May waive the rules of evidence
and shall note in the file the rationale
for this decision
I believe when you do shells and statues
it's a requirement always right it's
either May or shall
shall is right the Rules of Evidence
shall be applied but if there's a reason
that the judge has
um and this can be in consultation with
either the attorneys
um has reason to believe that the Rules
of Evidence would be adversity adverse
to the hearing allowing the judge to
waive those rules would be
um prudent and then he just needs to
note he or she needs to know why in the
case they did that for instance it's a
pro se respondent and the pro se
respondent doesn't necessarily know All
the Rules of Evidence so the pro se
respondent could in fact trip himself or
herself up on trying to respond to an
accusation because they aren't familiar
with court rules
um there might be a case where the state
as the plaintiff has compelling evidence
that would be difficult to admit because
it's a young it's a child in this case
and and the child can't testify
themselves we don't want the child to
testify so now it's second-hand
information but it needs to be presented
because it's relevant to the case so the
judge has that level of discretion in
section two
uh
excuse me for one second are there extra
copies of the amendment around could you
give one to attorney Ed I think since
oh um should be 30 copies or so it could
be yeah
how many would you like
okay
because I think this amendment really is
a good faith effort on the sponsor to
um take into account a variety of things
right the original bill when drafted put
it into court rules but it was so broad
it would have covered all family court
proceedings and it was never intended I
I would suggest you suspend for just a
minute sure
okay back up about three sentences and
start again
sure the bill has filed
the original bill
um OLS drafted into section 490--d which
has to do with oversight of Courts
the issue is it covers all
um Family Court proceedings and there
are other things that go on in family
courts other than child neglect and
abuse cases right this would have
impacted all cases relative to divorce
proceedings for instance some other
things
this is really about a narrow section of
that which is why the language actually
should have been put in 169-c to address
the cases what under 169 C
um
and then there was a May and Xiao right
um level of drafting issue that was
corrected in the amendment as well
so I would ask that you would consider
and debate on the amended version of
zero six one nine H as opposed to the
bill as filed
and it would be easy as the committee to
to default back to the bill but you've
all been provided and copies of this
we've provided copies to those in
attendance so that it can be discussed
um on this and it's simply establishing
a baseline so everybody knows the rules
of the game going into a court
proceeding
with that I'll close my testimony
any questions for representative hole
representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman you should just assume I have a
question I would suggest you alternate
arms otherwise you will wind up being
lopsided thank you it's possible it's
possible thank you representative Hull
um once again for coming before us
um
and for catching that legal reference
right away because that was one of my
big circled questions from before and
that changes
um my reading of this significantly
um so now I'm back to
um a question I'm gonna ask you about
the
um Amendment which is basically the same
thing
um my question is it seems to me that
your Roman numeral one and Roman numeral
two
are kind of In conflict with each other
and I'm wondering if you can speak a
little bit more about it because Roman
numeral one says that this the court
shall admit any evidence or testimony
offered by the respondent
but then number two says the court shall
apply the New Hampshire Rules of
Evidence
unless they waive it and give a reason
why so if they're does that mean that
the respondent
um can have whatever they wanted
admitted but then dcyf or a therapist or
whomever are held to a different
standard than the parent or are you
saying that
that they will admit it but they have to
have a footnote saying why they admitted
it so I'm like I'm confused about how
the two parts work together merge
together great question thank you so
that is a question I think I understood
it and to answer your question how do
sections Roman numeral one and Roman
Roman numeral two merge together and I
think we need to establish what is the
Rules of Evidence I would expect that if
dcyf is at a hearing
their attorneys are going to understand
the Rules of Evidence they will be able
to follow the rules they can go to the
judge and say I need to waive the Rules
of Evidence because of X right I have
compelling reason to waive the rules and
they can make that motion to the judge
that's going to be easy for an attorney
to do
um likewise the respondent or their
attorney could could do the same thing
this establishes the floor we all are
going to use the Rules of Evidence so we
have some process we have some
collective set of Standards by which
evidence is being applied both parties
can ask for a wave of the rules
the only thing that is required when
that happens is the judge has to know
why he or she is doing that and I think
that's the footnote in the case that
says look I believe that dcy have had
compelling evidence and I I okay but it
didn't comply with the rules the
standard Rules of Evidence so I admitted
it because it was relevant to the
hearing and would have adversely
affected the outcome and it doesn't
that's neutral language it's not right
in favor of the plaintiff or or the
respondent it's purely neutral Outland
because the judge may come may see
something in that evidence that is
valuable to making a decision so does
that help you understand how they merge
together
no it didn't I got halfway there so I
understand I because I think you spoke
to number two number two is the Rules of
Evidence shall apply unless there's some
compelling reason why they shouldn't and
so I'm hearing you say either the
respondent or dcyf can say here's why it
doesn't apply and the judge can make a
ruling but then number one says except
that doesn't apply to the respondent the
respondent can have whatever they want
admitted
so right yes okay so we're in sync and I
will explain why one is left for the
respondent
so this is a constitutional issue I
don't have my I do hold on the New
Hampshire Constitution right under part
first article 20 I think
um is is very similar language about all
proofs favorable to them right and that
has to do with criminal cases but in
this case it would apply as well
um
did you say you think it's article 20. I
want to say it's article 20. let me just
check real quick I'm happy to Google
that
[Music]
um
no it is not 20. it is
rights of the Q is 15 right no
um every subject shall have a right to
produce all proofs that may be favorable
to himself sorry it's written in single
gender at that point to meet with the
witnesses against them face to face and
to be fully heard in his defense by
himself and counsel and
that's regarding Criminal
criminal it doesn't and both in in all
of
um part first right of the
Constitutional Bill of Rights it does
address civil cases it talks about
Property Transfers it talks about
charges over fifteen hundred dollars
right requiring
um a jury trial so I would argue that in
this case right
where we're talking about child neglect
and abuse
accusations and we're talking about
potentially the removal of home which is
a punishment on par with a felony level
offense at least in my eyes that's right
it's certainly traumatic right it's
traumatic for all parties involved
including the child if we're if if the
state is getting that involved into the
case or right in that involved in the
family through this case there is Merit
to the respondent having
access to all proofs that are favorable
to him or her per the Constitution part
first Article 15 which is why it's
drafted I did not quote verbatim but it
is drafted to be very similar to that
style language
um and then remember the state has
effectively unlimited resources in a
dcyf case the respondent does not the
respondent has what their checkbook
allows or what they can borrow or what
their friends will give them that is a
very lopsided case when it comes to a
court hearing it's not two parties
laying
debating on even Financial playing field
almost always the responded is does not
have access to the same resources that
the state does
sure
any other questions for the
representative
seeing none thank you thank you the
chair recognizes Attorney Richard head
thank you Mr chairman thank you members
of the committee my name is Richard head
I'm the government Affairs coordinator
for the judicial branch
um
and I appreciate the sponsors
clarification in the amendment and I'm
just going to speak to the amendment as
opposed to the original bill on the
assumption that is going forward in that
way
um the amendment does help clarify in
terms of limiting it to the section and
or limiting it to 169 C
um
I do believe notwithstanding the
representative's explanation as to why
paragraphs one and two are not
inconsistent um they are inconsistent
and in paragraph one goes substantially
Beyond
what the Constitution provides in part
one Article 15
the the amendment in in paragraph Roman
one would read that on the court shall
admit any evidence or testimony in any
form offered by the respondent oops
um
in a Family Division case which the
respondent believes will be favorable to
his or her case
each one it still talks about Family
Division case but it's in 169 C so I
would have to assume that's limited to
169 C I think that needs to still be
clarified but the expansion is that
there shall admit any evidence or
testimony in any form so it is it
there's no res there's no capacity for
the judge to apply the rules of evidence
for example as to relevance and
so if if a uh respondent believed that
reading six U.S Supreme Court cases
front to back was favorable to his or
her case
they could do that I think under this
section they could because it requires
the court to admit the evidence in any
form offered by the respondent
and all the respondent has to say is I
believe this would be favorable to my
case so I think that is it is as written
extremely Broad and and does not allow
the court to apply any rules but simply
requires the court to allow the
testimony to occur in whatever form
forever however long it may actually
take
with regard to the second uh paragraph
um in the amendment which would again
apply only to 169 C truthfully I I did
not come prepared to I to talk about
why it is that the statute
in its current form says
um that the rules of evidence do not
have to apply and there was probably a
very good reason back when the when the
statute was uh passed
um it's been amended a couple times in
1979 and 2017 is the most recent and
truthfully because I didn't have the
amendment I didn't go back through and
try to identify exactly what was the
concern that was being addressed at the
time and I'd be concerned without more
information
um
that that we do try to identify that and
learn as to exactly what was being
protected
that said
um
in the phrasing of the bill in the
waiver language it says if the judge has
reason to believe that applying the
Rules of Evidence shall adversely affect
the case the judge May waive the Rules
of Evidence the judge does not look to
whether or not information adversely
affects a case that's really a uh a
litigant's role as to what supports a
case the judges is interested in what is
um in the best interest of Justice
um or or whatever this this the cases
that's reformed we're the judge is not
trying to figure out what is adversely
affecting someone's case because that
case has to be presented to the judge
the judge is not presenting the case to
the witness so it should have a standard
if there's if this is going to go
forward that the waiver would be
um that the judge could waive the rules
as Justice may require or some of the
other more standard language language
that you see in the statute under uh
providing the court with the authority
to waive I would however
just pausing that I
I would like more time to be able to
evaluate exactly why 169 C12 exists in
its current form and talk to some judges
as to sort of fact circumstances as to
as to how it does apply and I'd be happy
to supplement uh with the German's
permission uh my testimony in writing
um with that I would I'd like to give
you both a bite at the Apple not now but
later on the way towards two weeks from
now when we will exec it so to be fair
to you to do that I think that would be
a good thing to do and in the light of
some of these things I think the prime
sponsor will have some things to do as
well so bring it on both of you and
we'll do this in two weeks thank you
you're welcome
thank you uh the chair now recognizes uh
Keith kerning from Waypoint
Mr chairman members of the committee um
my name is Keith kenning for the record
I'm the office security director at wake
point we sit in opposition of this bill
um is written as amended
um I would just reiterate everything
that um attorney had said we have all
the same concerns and the same concerns
that representative Raymond has it's
particularly concerning the first
paragraph I agree in hearing under this
chapter the court shall admit any
evidence any evidence personal evidence
intimate evidence
in any form
offered by the respondent in the Family
Division case was the respondent beliefs
will be favorable to his or her case so
this is kind of like saying we're going
to have baseball rules but in the fifth
and sixth inning the visiting team can
do whatever they want
and the umpires can't do anything about
it and that just can't be if you're
going to have Rules of Evidence The
Rules of Evidence need to apply equally
to everyone I think trying to put the
Rules of Evidence in the family court is
literally like trying to put clothes
adult clothes on a child there are
reasons that they don't apply in a
family court there are many things
children don't understand from hearsay
to other things so you know that's
difficult but even if you decide you
wanted to do that and try to make that
work you can't have a system set up that
the respondent decides what goes into
the record and the judge just has no
ability to stop that I just I don't see
how the court system I agree with Mr
head you know somebody could decide to
go on for eight days admitting evidence
it'd be nothing the judge could do if if
the respondent said I consider this
relevant so I find this very concerning
that's what I wanted to say so thank you
very much thank you will you take any
questions sure are there any questions
for him to take
representative Bickford without having
to clear your throat
thank you very much Mr chairman
um you said that Rules of Evidence
should not apply I believe that's what
you said Family Court
currently I don't believe all the rules
of voting so they do not apply to family
court for for various reasons and you
think yes thank you for the question
um but go ahead I'm sorry I interrupted
you no that uh I was concerned about
where you're going with that you use the
terminology about adult clothes on a
child but I'm trying to understand
what rules do apply which ones don't and
just to understand the
the issue here
so thank you for the question my
understanding is and I'm I can guarantee
you I'm not the perfect person to ask
this question I just know there's more
flexibility in the family courts in
order to in order to accommodate the
needs of the family court that are
different from a normal court system and
so as I said if the committee decided
they wanted to apply the Rules of
Evidence perhaps that's something that
we should you could look into but you
can't apply the rules of evidence and
then say but it doesn't apply in certain
situations yeah I got that yeah okay
thank you thank you
seeing no further questions thank you so
much and making the assumption that the
card that representative Betty gay
handed in has her name on it
I'm good at this I will call
Representative gay
hey Betty K
thank you
I have a very my interpretation of this
is that Roman numeral two is really
really important
and what what I would do is I wouldn't
have one and two I'd have two well
renumber it and it would say
in all proceedings under this chapter
the court shall apply the New Hampshire
Rules of Evidence to any evidence or
testimony in any form offered by the
respondent in a Family Division case
which the respondent believes will be
favorable to his or her case
to enhance the predictable orderly fair
and reliable presentation of evidence
to me that's what it's really saying we
we want to allow the court the judge
to
study anything
and apply the rules and if he thinks
it's going to make the case not it's
going to twist the case you know
applying the exact wording
then he gets to gets to uh uh change it
and shall note in the file the rationale
we really would like records of when
rules are changed so to me Roman
numerals 2 says everything and what
Roman numeral says is could be included
in that sentence it's just that you have
the right to submit anything but the
judge is going to apply the rules of
evidence and has the freedom to dis to
disregard the exact letter of the law of
evidence as long as they know why they
did it
come on
give representative hole a call tonight
would you because he had to leave okay
any questions on that
okay seeing none seeing no one with a
pink card running up to get it under the
deadline
no
that wasn't a request
thank you close the hearing on 499
you could have you know I mean you could
have but
and that's it for the day and have fun
on tomorrow voting
and maybe Thursday snowstorm
and your week off
and I'll see you here in two weeks